alors mes chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons pour l'une de nos dernières
auditions de notre commission d'enquête
dont les travaux toucheront bientôt à
leur faim je suis heureux d'accueillir
la délégation du collectif bassine non
merci donc composé de Messieurs Julien
Legay Jérôme greffe et Jérémy Fougerat
ainsi que de Mesdames Anne mouvaine
Pasquier et Lucille Richard je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu positivement à
notre convocation puisque comme je
l'indiquais hier soir à la commission
telle n'a pas été le cas des
soulèvements de la terre ceux-ci nous
ayons indiqué qu'une action justice
étant en cours ils n'ont pas souhaité se
présenter devant la représentation
nationale alors cette audition se
déroule dans un contexte particulier que
je crois utile de préciser en ouverture
de nos échanges les règles de
fonctionnement des commissions d'enquête
leur interdisent d'investiguer je cite
sur des faits ayant donné dû à des
poursuites judiciaires aussi longtemps
que c'est poursuites sont en cours or
comme chacun sait effectivement les
procédures ouvertes à la suite des
événements de Sainte-Soline se
poursuivent au moment où nous nous
réunissons par conséquent nous ne
pouvons nous pencher sur la méthode ni
sur le cadre légal applicable ou les
inspirations idéologiques de chacun
notre rôle ne consiste évidemment ni à
rechercher des preuves ni à assigner des
responsabilités ça ça n'est pas dans le
périmètre de notre commission d'enquête
donc je me permets de le dire d'ailleurs
davantage à l'attention des membres de
la commission que j'invite à garder en
mémoire cette élément de l'égalité au
moment où vous exprimerez j'indique par
ailleurs aux auditionnés cette fois-ci
qu'il demeure libre de ne pas répondre à
une question dont il estimeraient
qu'elle expose potentiellement leur
responsabilité pénale eu égard aux
événements en question puisque encore
une fois nous nous tenons à vraiment
respecter le strict cadre légal de ce
qu'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire peut faire et également ne
pas faire alors Mesdames et Messieurs un
questionnaire vous a appris à
préalablement été transmis par notre
rapporteur donc monsieur Florent
Bouillet je vous invite à communiquer
vos réponses écrites dans le
prolongement de cette audition de votre
côté vous avez souhaité que des
documents soient mis à la disposition
des membres de la commission d'enquête
donc sachez qu'ils ont été communiqués à
la fois par voie électronique et
quelques exemplaires papier sont
également disponibles à l'entrée de la
salle donc pour que cette information
soit la plus la plus diffusée possible
alors j'en viens à l'objet de la
commission d'enquête qui porte comme
vous le savez sur les manifestations
violentes du printemps 2023 pour ce qui
concerne la présente audition nous
passerons rapidement sur la contestation
de la réforme des retraites et les
exactions commises en milieu urbain pour
nous concentrer cette fois-ci sur les
oppositions au projet d'infrastructures
qui sont motivés par des considérations
de nature environnementale votre
collectif combat la construction de
bassines destiné à l'irrigation agricole
et ce qui s'est passé en mars dernier à
attirer l'attention de tout le pays je
précise qu'une délégation de la
commission d'enquête a également eu
l'occasion de se rendre sur les lieux
donc un certain nombre de membres du
bureau se sont rendus sur sur place au
début du mois pour échanger avec les
autorités administratives d'une part et
les municipalités locales d'autre part
alors comme le l'usage il me revient
d'introduire nos échanges donc je vous
poserai les deux premières séries de
questions de l'audition je passerai
ensuite la parole
le cadre légal pour qu'on soit tous ce
qu'est en fait sur ce qu'on peut faire
ou non sur ce qu'on peut demander ou non
parce que vous pouvez rappeler si vous
l'avez qui est des questions oui
effectivement prenez le micro ici non ça
sera pas enregistré je sais pas si ça ça
mérite d'être au PV
c'est mieux oui très bien
vous avez rappelé le cadre légal
du périmètre afin qu'on doit soit tous
ok sur ce qu'on peut demander et pas
demander est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler quels sont les chefs de
poursuites qui sont connus s'ils
existent
qui sont opposés aux collectif bassines
non merci pour savoir ce qu'on peut
demander ce qu'on veut pas demander
parce que j'ai compris que vous nous
invitiez à être très attentif sur ce
cadre légal c'est ça
va être compliqué
voilà à vrai dire je n'ai pas moi ce
document donc je serai incapable de le
faire mais éventuellement si un moment
donné le collectif souhaite le faire ils
pourront le faire puisque si doivent je
pense le savoir en tout cas en premier
lieu pouvez-vous nous présenter les
moyens d'action que privilégie votre
collectif
êtes-vous actif sur le terrain
administratif
juridictionnelle politique électorale
idéologique
en matière d'éducation comment
définiriez-vous votre engagement
certains utiliseraient mais je le mets
volontairement entre guillemets votre
degré de radicalité y a-t-il des lignes
rouges que vous refusez de franchir en
matière de d'action militante des
actions auxquelles vous refusez
délibérément de prendre part et en
second lieu pouvez-vous présenter votre
organisation donc qu'elle est un peu
l'historique de du collectif bassine non
merci
combien de membres composent le
collectif
quel comment dire
comment alors que vous êtes une
association juridiquement constituée
organisez-vous et et financez vous vos
actions alors peut-être que voilà vous
vous apporterez la réponse si la réponse
est non
ça nous intéresse simplement de de le
savoir et plus précisément recevez-vous
des soutiens institutionnels ou
d'organismes publics alors comme le veut
la forme
mesdames et messieurs avant de vous
donner la parole et en application donc
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
nécessairement de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité comme j'ai
cru comprendre que vous aviez
potentiellement tous vocation à vous
exprimer il s'agit de de d'empêcher
personne de la délégation de s'exprimer
je vais vous demander de vous exprimer
donc successivement donc à commencer ma
madame pastier donc je vais vous
demander de d'abord de brancher votre
micro et de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure je le jure je vous
remercie si vous pouvez l'éteindre pour
que monsieur Legay puisse faire de même
je le jure merci beaucoup madame Richard
je le jure merci à vous monsieur
Fougerat je le jure merci beaucoup et je
le jure merci à vous et donc sans tarder
je vous passe déjà la parole et pour
vous indiquer le déroulement de la
séance dans un second temps je donnerai
évidemment aussi la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur puisque c'est c'est à lui
qu'il reviendra aussi d'effectuer le
rapport de notre commission d'enquête
puis
au membre de la commission d'enquête qui
souhaiterait également s'exprimer donc
et vous vous posez des questions donc a
priori avec un timing de deux minutes
par par intervention je précise une
dernière chose notre objectif est de
faire en sorte que l'on puisse le plus
possible évidemment s'approcher de la
réalité et nous poursuivons puisque une
commission d'enquête est aussi
transpartisane de faire en sorte que
l'on cherche à objectiver le plus
possible évidemment les choses donc sans
tarder je vous passe la parole mesdames
et messieurs et je vous laisse le soin
de décider comment vous organisez cette
prise de parole merci beaucoup je vous
remercie monsieur le Président pour
toutes ces informations et sur le
déroulé j'ai une petite question avant
qu'on se lance est-ce qu'il y a un temps
imparti est-ce qu'il y a une limite de
temps non il y a pas dans l'absolu il y
a pas de dans ma partie mais mais très
clairement on avait on avait fixé de
deux heures d'audition donc voilà on se
si ça déborde de quelques minutes si
c'est nécessaire l'objectif est
généralement de faire en sorte que
comment dire toute les échanges puissent
se faire je dirais normalement donc
voilà donc
théoriquement 18h voilà très bien vous
avez peut-être aussi certains d'entre
vous ont peut-être aussi des trains à
prendre voilà donc on va tâcher de
mettre dans ce créneau là et de faire le
tour de toutes les questions qui
pourront être posées
pour répondre à vos questions ça tombe
bien parce que en ouverture on a préparé
un texte linéaire qu'on va lire à quatre
voix et qui répondront à vos premières
interrogations avant c'est mis d'accord
on a une petite question à vous demander
si c'est faisable parce que ça n'a
jamais été clair allez-y jusqu'à
maintenant de savoir en quelle qualité
nous étions auditionnés ce jour en fait
vous vous êtes auditionné dans la mesure
où comment dire on est sur
nous on essaye de de comprendre ce qui a
pu se passer dans un certain nombre de
manifestations ou des expressions
extrêmement violentes sont intervenus et
donc comme vous vous êtes un collectif
qui appeler à la manifestation de sainte
Soline voilà il nous a semblé
important de pouvoir avoir un échange
avec vous à ce sujet donc c'est bien en
tant que structure organisatrice de
l'événement
affirmatif et donc dans le texte
imminaire on reviendra un petit peu
borné toutes les limites juridiques et
voilà ça va venir on redit d'éléments
que vous avez donné on va donner un peu
plus d'éléments pour expliciter un peu
le cadre quelqu'un de rejudiciaire dont
je fais l'objet en particulier
donc voilà on va vous lire ce texte
limitaire à plusieurs voix vous remercie
par avance de votre écoute je le
président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés vous
nous avez convoqué pour nous entendre
dans le cas de la commission d'enquête
relative à l'organisation des
groupuscules violents à manifestation
est-ce que ça va au niveau du son pour
tout le monde
le collectif bassinon merci est
constitué de simples citoyennes et
citoyens ainsi que d'organisation divers
et variées incluant des syndicats des
associations de protection de la nature
d'usagers d'usagère et même des partis
politiques il est créé en septembre 2017
en réaction au projet de méga bassines
sur le bassin versant la saviortaise et
du Marais Poitevin aujourd'hui sont plus
de 10 collectifs locaux constitués
partout en France ou des projets de méga
bassines ont émergé depuis notre
collectif c'est tout de suite constitué
tel que nous vous le présentons
aujourd'hui divers informel un
fonctionnement horizontal sans dirigeant
aux dirigeantes créatifs pacifique et
déterminé c'est au titre de la fonction
de porte-parole du collectif de la Sèvre
Niortaise Marais Poitevin que votre
commission m'a convoqué nommément ce
jour pas au titre de meneur ni de
représentant légal
et en aucun cas de dirigeant
en tout cas c'est pas ce titre là que je
me présente devant vous nous avions dû
surseoir à notre première convocation
juillet dernier d'une part parce que mon
état de santé ne me le permettait pas
mais également parce qu'un doute
subsistait et subsiste toujours quand
elle a conformité l'égalité de cette
audition en effet l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance numéro 58 1100 du 17
novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires stipulent qui
ne peut être créé de commission
d'enquête sur des faits ayant donné lieu
à des poursuites judiciaires et aussi
longtemps que c'est poursuites sont en
cours c'est une commission a déjà été
créée sa mission prend fin dès
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
relative au fait sur lesquelles elle est
chargée d'enquêter voilà c'est ce qui
fait qu'on s'est posé la question savoir
s'il était pertinent de se présenter
devant vous jusqu'à l'heure
pourrez-vous monsieur le Président nous
détailler plus précisément non je
voulais excusez-moi en tant que
porte-parole je fais l'objet d'une
procédure judiciaire qui m'a conduit
avec 8 camarades devant le tribunal de
Niort celui de septembre ce jugement est
en suspens et nous devrons comparer à
nouveau le 28 novembre de mon devant
cette même juridiction parmi les
questions qui nous sont adressées dans
le formulaire de cette commission une
grande partie correspondent au mot près
parfois à des questions couvertes par le
secret de l'instruction et à des
questions déjà posées par le juge du
Rafour ou par le procureur vous
comprendrez donc aisément pourquoi nous
nous autoriserons à ne pas répondre à
certaines questions ni lors de cette
audition ni dans les réponses aux
questionnaires que nous vous remettrons
ultérieurement certaines réponses
concernant notamment la chronologie des
faits son contenues dans le rapport de
la Ligue des droits de l'homme et à ce
titre là il y aura des réponses
apportées mais on en reparle après la
question
c'est néanmoins posée au sein de notre
collectif jusqu'au dernier moment de
répondre à votre convocation ou de se
limiter à une simple réponse écrite au
questionnaire rédigé par vos services
comme on choisit nos camarades et
soulèvements de la terre ou de la
Confédération paysanne nous venons ici
devant vous et devant les caméras de
l'Assemblée nationale pour qu'un autre
récit basé sur les éléments factuels
puissent être entendus consignés dans
votre rapport final archiver et ainsi
consultable par toutes et tous et pour
les décennies à venir
après avoir visionné la plupart des
auditions de cette commission nous
constatons que certains
osent encore remettre le question en
question le bilan final dramatique de la
manifestation de Sainte-Souline
véritable fiasco en termes d'opération
de maintien de l'ordre avec plus de 200
blessés chez les manifestants et
manifestants et une quarantaine chez les
forces de l'ordre ça ne solide doit
rester dans l'histoire de cet épisode où
une stratégie de maintien de l'ordre par
l'envoi massif d'engins explosifs à
éclat aura impacté la vie de milliers de
militantes et de militants des luttes
écologiques la première fois qu'un État
européen aura traité aussi durement et
massivement une marche pacifiste pour la
défense de l'eau comme bien commun
le gouvernement n'aurait jamais dû
donner les ordres et les consignes ayant
entraîné un tel feu de bombe militaire
en tout genre et sans aucun discernement
il n'aurait jamais dû prendre le risque
de tuer un ou une citoyenne ou une
gamine un papy un jeune sous prétexte
qu'il portait une capuche juste pour
protéger un cratère géant la protection
des personnes doit primer sur celle des
biens pour illustrer la diversité de
bassines non merci nous sommes 4 à nous
présenter devant vous Julien Legay
batelier et porte-parole de bassines non
merci Lucile Richard archéologue et
rapporteuse du collectif auprès de la
Commission européenne Petty Anne more
one pastier docteur en Sciences de la
Terre et qui a notamment travaillé à
dénoncer les limites majeures et la
partialité des études produites par le
BRGM sur comment des porteurs de projets
la société anonyme et coopérative de
l'eau des Deux-Sèvres
et moi-même docteur Jérémy Fougerat
médecin généraliste membre de l'équipe
médicale de la manifestation autorisée
de mails Monsieur Jérôme greffe membre
de la Ligue des droits de l'homme et
observateur de la LDH dure la
manifestation de Sainte-Souline nous
accompagne il a contribué à la rédaction
du rapport sens solide 24/26 mars
empêcher l'accès à la bassine quel que
soit le coût humain il pourra ainsi
répondre aux questions concernant le
déroulé des faits lors de cet événement
au sein du collectif bassine non merci
des militantes et des militants des
personnalités politiques des paysans des
paysannes des scientifiques lutte contre
l'implantation de soi-disant solutions
de stockage d'eau qui permettrait de
restaurer le bon état des cours d'eau
pour rappel les bassines sont des
dispositifs de sécurisation de
l'irrigation uniquement de parcelle
agricole qui sont raccordés pour les
construire des hectares de terres
agricoles sont éradiqués la terre
végétale est évacuée la roche creusée et
damée la surface nue est ensuite
entièrement bâchée des kilomètres de
canalisation sont construits et plus
rien ne repoussera sur ses terres avant
des décennies voire des siècles quelques
forages vont remplir ces mégas bassines
pendant quelques mois en hiver privant
possiblement des zones de leur cru
annuel et risquant de ne pas permettre
la recharge maximale des nappes cette
eau va ensuite être exposée à la lumière
et à la chaleur la forme des bassines
favorise cette exposition qui a pour
conséquence une évaporation partielle de
l'eau ainsi qu'une perte de qualité avec
le développement possible d'algues
causant une autre utilisation voire de
cyanobactéries ou de légionellose
Sébastien sont installés dans des zones
de répartition des eaux c'est à dire des
régions où l'on sait depuis une
trentaine d'années que la consommation
d'eau notamment à des fins de suret
irrigation agricole est supérieure à la
capacité du milieu au-delà du problème
posé par les bassines c'est l'ensemble
de l'incohérence de la gestion de l'eau
que nous questionnons dans l'ensemble de
nos actions sont partagées équitables
aussi bien des populations au sein des
populations qu'entre les humaines et les
non-humaines par la surconsommation
d'eau qu'elle s'encourage les bassines
ne font pas partie de la solution des
conflits d'usage de l'eau que l'on voit
déjà arriver mais bel et bien du
problème et qu'en dire dans la
perspective du réchauffement climatique
dans un monde à plus 4 degrés par
rapport à l'air pré-industriel un monde
auquel le président de la République
nous demande de nous adapter les modèles
du GIEC s'accordent pour prédire des
sécheresses pluriannuelles intenses
pouvant durer jusqu'à plus de 9 années
consécutives
les bassines seront-elles haut toujours
aussi rentables pour les raccorder vous
vous en doutez de tels ont rapidement
soulevé lire des habitants les plus
sensibles à leur environnement dès les
premières constructions il y a plus de
15 ans en Vendée et en Charente-Maritime
depuis 7 ans ce mouvement s'est
réellement amplifié suite à l'annonce
d'un nouveau projet de bassine dans les
Deux-Sèvres principalement le retour
d'expérience des premières bassines ne
permettait que de constater les
promesses non tenues là où les bassines
avaient pris place la culture du maïs
régnait comme jamais au contraire d'un
changement vers une politique de
sobriété dans les usages agricoles de
l'eau ces méga bassines entretiennent
l'illusion d'une ressource facilement
accessible et quasi inépuisable
notre première initiative fut de
participer aux enquêtes publiques et
même d'en faire la promotion auprès de
nos concitoyens en mars 2017 l’enquête
publique comprenait 449 contributions
avec 70% d'avis défavorable pourtant un
avis favorable des commissaires
enquêteurs étaient mis à partir de ce
véritable déni de démocratie la
résistante s'est organisée chaque
composante jouant sa partition les
associations de protection de la nature
et de l'environnement on collectivement
porté de nombreux recours devant la
justice administrative à ce jour c'est
la troisième version de l'arrêté
préfectoral qui se retrouve jugée devant
la cour d'appel du tribunal
administratif de Bordeaux tous les
épisodes juridiques précédents ayant
abouti à une modification des arrêtés
antérieures donnant ainsi raison au
requérant
les premières victoires juridiques n'ont
pourtant pas stoppé ces projets tout au
contraire les premières mobilisations
massives ont alors eu lieu et ont permis
à des milliers d'habitants de se
retrouver pour dire leur attachement à
leur territoire et leur opposition à
l'accaparement de l'eau
nous avons organisé de très nombreuses
conférences projection débat
intervention colloques tribune et
communication diverses pour permettre
aux habitants de se s'informer de monter
en compétences et de pouvoir dénoncer et
contrecarrer les mensonges diffusés
couramment dans les médias comme celui
d'un remplissage des bassines par l'eau
de pluie par exemple
par cette mobilisation polymorphe et
pluriel nous avons réussi pendant près
de quatre ans à maintenir un rapport de
force tels que les travaux étaient
chaque fois repoussés jusqu'à ce mois de
septembre 2021 où les premières grilles
du chantier de la bassine de Mauzé ont
été posées
aboutissant à la première construction
du projet de Sévrier
vous devrez vous devez comprendre
mesdames et messieurs les députés
comment se démarrage de travaux alors
que les arrêtés étaient encore sous le
coup de différents recours a été vécu
comme un véritable bafouement des règles
les plus élémentaires en matière de
protection de la nature et de la
protection de l'eau
bien commun il inaliénable
vous devez entendre ici mesdames et
messieurs les députés à quel point cette
situation porte en elle le germe des
colères et des soulèvements à venir et
qui animent aujourd'hui une grande
partie de celles et ceux qui
s'investissent pour la préservation de
toutes les formes du vivant et des
générations futures
c'est suite au démarrage des travaux que
nos modes d'action ont changé et que
nous nous sommes autorisés à agir dans
le champ de la désobéissance civile
de nombreux précédents expliquent un
véritable sentiment de défiance
vis-à-vis de l'État dans ses projets
d'aménagement
comment interpréter le cas du lac de
Caussade
grande retenue d'eau à vocation
agricoles construite illégalement
aujourd'hui utilisé alors que l'ouvrage
devait être démoli et la zone humide
réhabilité
idem pour le chantier de Sivens pilotez
lui aussi par la même CACG compagnie
d'aménagement des coteaux de gaz comme
que les bassines
que les racines qui n'aura du son arrêt
qu'à la mort de Rémi Fraisse
que dire enfin des six bassines de Laza
des roches en Charente-Maritime jugée
illégale tout au long d'un parcours
judiciaire long de 10 ans mais néanmoins
construite sur autorisation préfectorale
lors de la manifestation de novembre
2021 à Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon nous avons
vécu nos premières menaces sur nos
libertés de manifester et avons eu à
subir la mise en place de périmètres
d'interdiction de manifester élargies et
inédits de par leurs dimensions rendant
inenvisageable tout accès à la
bastinence chantier malgré le
ressentiment généré par ces arrêtés
liberticides notre collectif les
organisations co-organisatrices ont
décidé de rester sur la zone libre et
d'aller montrer ce qui était une méga
bassine sur la commune riveraine de
cran-chaban
en dépit des engagements de la
préfecture de nous laisser cheminer
notre cortège était bloqué au premier
obstacle le passage d'un pont sous la
voie ferrée le rapport de confiance
était alors rompu de manière spontanée
l'ensemble du cortège prenez le chemin
de la rivière mignon à sec et
franchissez l'obstacle sous un premier
feu nourri de bombe lacrymogène premier
de l'histoire de notre lutte jetez
pêle-mêle sur les enfants les anciens et
les anciennes qui participaient à se
rassemblement qui se voulait pacifiste
comment auriez-vous réagi ce jour
mesdames et messieurs les députés dans
cette rivière de votre enfance asséchée
par les canons à eau agricoles
environnants quand vous vous retrouvez
sous ces nuages sous ces nuages toxiques
alors que vous cheminiez pacifiquement
que vous voyez vos proches pris à parti
vos petits-enfants ces poumonner que
pensez-vous que c'est la génère comme
pensée vis-à-vis des autorités des
préfets des agents des forces de l'ordre
quand ils utilisent de tels moyens alors
même qu'aucune dégradation aucune
provocation n'était venue durant des
manifestants juste faire valoir notre
liberté de manifester de nous déplacer
de nous regrouper de nous exprimer
comment pensez-vous
que vous réagiriez si suite à ça vous
aviez vu toutes les manifestations
systématiquement interdites nous avons
refusé de nous plier aux interdictions
systématiques et autoritaires nous avons
continué à nous rassembler et à nous
donner les moyens de circuler le plus
librement possible sur ce territoire qui
est le nôtre et que nous défendons dans
la diversité côté de ces modes d'action
notre collectif a aussi participé à
l'organisation d'événements plus
sportifs comme les descentes de Sèvres
et du Clain en canoë ou encore récemment
le convoi de l'eau en une manifestation
en tracteur et vélo de près de 400 km
qui s'est conclu par une arrivée festive
à l'Agence de l'Eau Loire Bretagne les
négociations qui sont tenues entre nos
organisations et la préfète de bassin
ont été que le dernier épisode
illustrant le mépris de l'État dans ce
problème vis-à-vis des citoyens de ce
territoire alors que le convoi de l'eau
c'était déroulé sans affrontement alors
que nous représentants tes représentants
n'ont fait que demander une suspension
des travaux qui était elle-même demandée
par la mission de médiation portée par
le comité de bassin de la même agence de
l'eau alors que les violences des dégâts
des dégâts irréversibles sur le chantier
de prière débutait avec la destruction
d'une d'un nouvel espace d'une dizaine
d'hectares au moment même où nous étions
négociations l'État n'a pas dénié mettre
un frein dans l'escalade des tensions
l'histoire de cette lutte c'est
l'histoire d'un blocage démocratique
c'est l'histoire de l'épuis de tous les
recours légaux et de toutes les formes
d'action que vous qualifiez de
pacifistes ce blocage l'institutionnel
va de pair avec une intensification de
la répression des mouvements écologistes
et la porosité inquiétante contraire au
principe fondamental de séparation des
pouvoirs notamment lorsque le garde des
sceaux donne ses consignes au magistrat
pour nos jugements et c'est bien la
stratégie de l'attention elle est
dispositifs arrêtés liberticides qui
sont de nature à entretenir un climat
explosif nous exigeons une nouvelle fois
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée un
moratoire sur les chantiers de bassine
et sur leur financement un respect des
décisions de justice
un respect des décisions des données
scientifiques et la mise en place de
concertation publique et élargie c'est
comme ça qu'on crée la confiance au sein
du peuple qu'on ouvre le dialogue pour
permettre la construction de solution
réellement collective et d'intérêt
général pas en balançant des tonnes de
grenades impactantes gm2l la seule
sortie de crise possible c'est de
recréer les conditions d'écoute et de
respect de l'ensemble des citoyens des
citoyens ainsi que la mise en place
d'instance de l'eau
affranchi de l'emprise de la FNSEA et de
la grande industrie mesdames et
messieurs merci de nous avoir écoutés
très bien je vais passer maintenant la
parole à Monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
donc je vous laisse peut-être poser une
première question puis comme ça voilà
comme ça vous pourrez avoir quelques
quelques échanges
merci monsieur le président
monsieur Legay vous avez interrogé notre
commission le président en particulier
sur la légalité de nos commissions
d'enquête
nous ne sommes pas partisans de la
désobéissance civile
par rapport au règlement intérieur de
l'Assemblée nationale nous le respectons
et donc nous avons sollicité le garde
des sceaux comme c'est
obligatoire pour s'assurer que nous
pouvions organiser cette commission
d'enquête dont le principe a été voté
par l'hémicycles pas simplement par
quelques députés de façon à ce que il y
est une séparation stricte et donc tout
ce qui concerne des parcours individuels
des actes qui seraient reprochés à des
individus n'est pas évoqué en propre
nous regarderons avec vous si vous
acceptez de répondre à vos questions la
totalité du déroulement la chronologie
les éléments que nous avons pu
éventuellement constater sur place enfin
voilà vous appelez au respect de la
légalité c'est une question qui se
posera également vis-à-vis d'un certain
contact que vous avez pu engager
notamment à l'occasion de cette
manifestation du 25 mars
je vais essayer de poser quelques
questions
par ordre si vous le permettez monsieur
le Président première question celle qui
vient le plus rapidement à l'esprit
évidemment c'est la relation entre votre
structure je ne sais pas comment la
nommer donc pardon pour le terme s'il
est inadapté et le représentant de
l'État dans le département la préfète
pour dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont comment on amont de cette
manifestation s'est régulé le dialogue
avec l'autorité administrative est-ce
que vous avez senti l'état pré au
dialogue vous avez considéré que le
dialogue n'était pas possible est-ce que
vous avez souhaité de toute façon que ce
dialogue n'est pas lieu voilà c'est un
éclairage important je pense pour nos
travaux
je vais vous laisser
répondre enfin décidé de qui qui
intervient pour pour les réponses
c'est évoqué dans le texte limitaire
notamment mais je peux redire pendant 5
ans de cette lutte on a organisé toute
une manifestations elles étaient
déclarées il y avait des rencontres avec
les services d'ordre pour établir les
tracés etc et on évoque vraiment un fait
qu'un schisme dans notre relation avec
les l'État c'est suite à une première
une manifestation mois de septembre ou
la deuxième manifestation qu'on fait au
mois d'octobre à Mauzé-sur-le-Mignon les
c'est la première fois il y a des
arrêtés liberticides dans les qualifient
bien comme ça en tout cas nous on sent
vraiment nos libertés fondamentales
diminuées puisqu'on voulait tout
simplement pouvoir les montrer à des
gens qui ne savaient pas ce qui était
une méga bassine allez voir sur le
terrain se rendre compte de visu à quoi
ça ressemblait et on a rencontré une
première batterie d'interdiction et donc
avec l'interorga avec les l'ensemble des
organisations qui appellent assez
manifestations nous avions fait le choix
de ne pas
dépasser cette limite là et comme on le
dit dans le texte d'aller voir un autre
secteur qui n'était pas en rouge et il y
a eu une véritable obstruction d'emblée
des services d'ordre qui n'étaient pas à
leur place qui venaient nous obstruer
une nouvelle fois dans et à partir de ce
moment-là ce que je dis pas dans le
texte c'est que ça généré le fait que
cette bassine de laser des roches elle a
suite à ça et je dis vraiment suite à ça
parce que c'est ça ça ne passe qui
serait arrivé si on est n'avions pas été
entravé si la première tension n'était
pas apparue s'il y avait pas eu ses
premiers jets de lacrymo sur des
cortèges qui se voulaient qui se
revendiquait pacifiste
il y aurait pas eu de destruction de la
bassine de crachats dans la foulée
voilà tout simplement ça a été un effet
de réaction immédiat à cette violence
qui a été vraiment subie comme une
violence à un arbitraire fort
je rappelle que cette bassine en fait on
l'a elle a été débâchée collectivement
elle a assumé par l'ensemble des
organisations cette bassine est illégale
et cette bassine aurait dû déjà être
mise en état et les porteurs de projets
auraient dû financer la remise et le
bouchage du trou depuis belle lurette
encore moins cette bassine elle continue
d'être utilisée enfin ses bassines
jumelles de laser des roches continue
d'être utilisés aujourd'hui donc on
garde ce réflexe systématiquement à
chacun de nos événements de continuer à
faire nos déclarations de manifestations
ça a encore été le cas pour ça de solide
et une nouvelle fois là ça a été une
semaine en amont souvent c'est deux
trois jours en amont on a appris que
cette manifestation serait interdite et
doubler à ça de quantité d'arrêter
annexes et supplémentaire pour interdire
toutes sortes de
avec l'autorité administrative des
échanges formels
en tant que médecin qui était
responsable du dispositif
sanitaire de mail
j'ai participé à une réunion à la
commission de sécurité le mardi qui
précédait le 25 mars ou étaient présents
les services de la préfecture le SAMU
les pompiers les gendarmes la mairie de
Mel
et une délégation des organisateurs
donc je trouve ça illustre très bien le
fait que il y avait une communication
qui était possible dans la mesure où la
manifestation était autorisée
et que évidemment il y avait du fait de
l'interdiction préalable une
impossibilité d'aller aborder ce sujet
là
qui me semblait être préjudiciable mais
et génératrice de risque
mais en fait le il y a une discussion
possible quand il y a un cadre possible
quand un cadre permet cette discussion
voilà
est-ce que ces occasions des éléments
dans les échanges écrits ou verbaux avec
la préfecture est-ce que l'autorité
administrative vous communique les
éléments d'inquiétude
pour les services de l'État tenant à la
sécurité de l'événement ou pas
en fait dans ce jeu de ping-pong
administratif je dis bien en fait une
manifestation ça se déclare c'est pas
une demande d'autorisation et
systématiquement donc on a subi des
refus des interdictions systématiquement
on est allé devant les juridictions pour
obtenir les référés liberté et notamment
dans les faits qui étaient régulièrement
mis sur la table il y avait le rappel
des épisodes précédents mais qui en
réalité à son sujet à caution par
exemple le fait que dans nos
rassemblements il est parfois aller
soulèvements de la terre qui fasse
partie des associations ou des
organisations co-organisatrices on va
nous dire que elle était taxée
d'une décision du Conseil d'État enfin
d'une décision de dissolution et être
activement aujourd'hui la dissolution a
été suspendue donc ça veut dire que cet
élément là qui figurait parmi les griefs
et qui semblait recevable devant les
tribunal lucratifs à cette époque là
n'est plus recevable en l'état et on n'a
pas aujourd'hui fait des recours sur le
fond
mais c'est décisions préfectorales
d'interdiction de manifestations qui
sont souvent prises en urgence sont
attaquables et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
ça fait partie des batailles juridiques
qu'on est prête à mener
nous sommes bien d'accord que donc ces
décisions ces arrêtées administratives
préfectoraux ont été attaqués par
vous-même devant la jurisprudence
administrative la juridiction
administrative à chaque fois et y
compris pour le 25 mars
oui ça a suivi le même cursus il m'a
mémoire est bonne après dans le
l'enchaînement de toutes nos péripéties
etc depuis 6 ans mais oui c'est notre
démarche systématique en effet
vous arrêtez administratifs qui sont
donc validés par le juge administratif
ne sont pas par conséquent illégaux il
s'inscrit dans un cadre légal je tiens
quand même à le rappeler si nous
reprenons cette fois-ci la chronologie
lorsque nous sommes allés sur place nous
avons pu rencontrer un stand d'acteurs
je ne parle pas de celles et ceux qui
défendent le principe des bassines de la
même façon que je ne veux pas rentrer
dans le débat de l'opportunité ou pas du
principe même des bassines ce n'est pas
l'objet de notre commission d'enquête
raison pour laquelle je ne veux pas
rentrer dans ce dans ce débat en
revanche les élus locaux
les locaux qui que nous avons rencontrés
ont indiqué que dès le vendredi 24 mars
et ceci dès l'après-midi du vendredi 24
mars donc plusieurs heures avant même
que la manifestation ne se déroule
un certain nombre d'individus qui
manifestement ne sont pas là pour
manifester
mais sont équipés sont
ultra mobiles circulent à grande vitesse
précisément pour interrompre une ligne
en vitesse par exemple ces individus
sont visibles les élus locaux s'en
inquiète les notes les voix également en
soirée et font bien la distinction je
crois que je parle sous le contrôle de
l'ensemble des collègues qui étaient
présents entre les manifestants qui
effectivement répondent au profil que
vous avez évoqué monsieur Legay
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui sont là
pour défendre une cause qui le font dans
l'engagement qui est le leur
parfois avec des amis avec la famille de
façon relativement festive de festivités
qui sont organisés en parallèle de la
manifestation à venir qui font le
distinguer entre ces profils précis
et des individus nature violentes
je parle de maire de communes modeste
qui n'ont aucune expérience
de la gestion du maintien de l'ordre et
encore moins de la gestion d'une
manifestation de plusieurs milliers de
personnes dans des villages de 350
habitants c'est le cas pour ça ne solide
est-ce que vous avez fait le même
constat sur place monsieur Legay
je me demande si spécifiquement dans
votre question on n'est pas sur cette
zone de bascule des questions qui
pourraient mettre posées par le juge du
Rafour
néanmoins je veux bien vous donner un
élément
moi je ne sais pas comment on reconnaît
un élément radicalisé ou un élément
soit pouvant commettre des violences je
vais vous dire que le fait d'être masqué
aujourd'hui ne qualifie pas une
détermination à la violence dans la
mesure aujourd'hui systématiquement le
fait de participer à une de nos réunion
peu donner des poursuites juridiques que
ce soit participation à un groupement on
a près d'une vingtaine de camarades qui
ont été interpellés sur ce chef
d'incubation là aujourd'hui le simple
fait de se présenter ou d'être sur la
route de ne nous manifestations peut
faire l'objet de l'interpellation donc
aujourd'hui ce masquer c'est vouloir
continuer à manifester sans faire
pouvoir faire l'objet d'une
interpellation et d'une garde à vue à
suivre
donc je ne ferai pas de de parallèle et
de signes égal avec le fait qu'il faille
présumer que ce sont des gens qui sont
là pour commettre des violences je vous
rappelle également que dans notre long
cheminement militants et toutes les
manifestations qu'on fait maintenant
depuis 7 ans toujours très populaire
familiale etc même à Sainte Soline
il y a une époque on nous a demandé
d'être masqué en manifestation et
qu'aujourd'hui on est aussi dans une
situation où il y a des réminiscences de
covid et il pourrait y avoir au sein de
manifestations des gens qui soient
masqués pour des raisons sanitaires ou
de la crainte d'être dans un groupe et
de pouvoir être contaminé donc
c'est factuel c'est factuel et en tout
cas je vous dis aujourd'hui moi j'ai
plein de gens
non mais attendez
s'exprimer
l'objectif d'une commission d'enquête
c'est voilà c'est de essayer de faire en
sorte que on puisse avoir un échange
voilà j'espère chers collègues que vous
respecterez la sonalité j'ai moi d'être
factuel mais je pourrais vous faire
parvenir les arrêtés préfectoraux qui
nous demandaient à ce que dans nos
manifestations nous incitons au port du
masque
juste un point de précision mais c'est
dans le droit fil des questions que vous
posez
quand nous avons eu cet échange avec les
maires en question mais sainte Soline en
fait il faisait état de personnes qui il
y a la tenue vestimentaire qui qui dans
certains cas a été mentionné par eux
mais ça ne se limitait pas la question
de la tenue vestimentaire c'est-à-dire
que l'autre élément qui était mentionné
c'est que ils ont été inquiétés de voir
arriver certaines personnes porteurs de
certains objets et notamment on nous a
mentionné batte de baseball ce genre de
choses en disant voilà là on a on a
commencé à avoir en quelque sorte une
situation où nous étions enfin du moins
pareil je parle sous le contrôle des
autres personnes qui étaient présentes
les maires ont senti une tension qui
montait parce que il semblait percevoir
des individus qui de toute évidence
n'était pas là pour je dirais une
promenade bucolique dans les champs mais
une volonté en tout cas de d'exprimer de
quelques manières que ce soit je dirais
des des formes des des formes
d'agressivité donc voilà donc je est-ce
que alors encore une fois la question
est très simple est-ce que vous avez
vous avez eu cette perception ou point
du tout
alors je vais revenir moi aussi sur
cette distinction que vous semblez faire
entre des manifestants manifestants qui
seraient assez festifs et d'autres qui
viendraient uniquement dans le l'optique
de tout casser sans avoir aucun rapport
aux causes écologistes qu'on défend en
fait
il faut voir que le jour de la
manifestation le 25 mars personne ne
vient dans une optique assez festive et
que de plus en plus dans les
manifestations
en ce qui me concerne depuis les
manifestations loi travail en 2016 les
gens viennent avec des objets alors je
vais pas parler des bas de baseball mais
en tout cas le fait de se masquer
d'avoir des lunettes d'avoir des masques
d'avoir des capuches par exemple pour
pas que les grenades explosives nous
restent à l'intérieur de nos cols et
nous tuent comme Rémy Fraisse c'est le
second des réflexes que quand on est
manifestant aujourd'hui on les a acquis
depuis maintenant des années et on
arrive et on se protège en fait on est
obligé même si on arrive avec les
intentions les plus
devenir faire si notre intention était
de venir faire une promenade bucolique
dans les champs je peux vous dire
Monsieur le Président que
personnellement j'y viens quand même
masquer avec des lunettes avec une
capuche voir avec un casque voir avec
plusieurs épaisseurs de vêtements pour
pouvoir encaisser les tirs de bébé donc
cette distinction vraiment entre des
manifestations des manifestants
bucoliques pacifistes et de l'autre côté
des blocs qui seraient uniquement là
pour avoir une liberté d'exercer une
violence elle n'existe que dans la
excusez-moi de le dire mais que dans la
tête de gens qui ne vont pas dans ces
manifestations
donc pas de dissection à faire entre
manifestants et casseurs
comment expliquer vous nous retrouvions
par conséquent des boules de pétanque
des machettes des objets qui ont été
volontairement élaborés pour porter
atteinte
on peut l'imaginer en tout cas
l'intégrité physique des forces de
l'ordre par exemple donc vous ne faites
pas la distinction mais manifestement il
y a des éléments tangibles matériels qui
permettent j'allais dire assez
radicalement de faire des distinctions
j'ai une réponse évidente à ça monsieur
le rapporteur
en amont de la manifestation de melsan
Soline sur cinq jours il y a eu 24 000
contrôles sur la zone contrôle qui
touchait également les habitants de ce
territoire manifestant ou pas
manifestant et quand on voit la
définition de l'arme par destination
c'est vrai que dans nos coffres et dans
vos coffres et bien il y a tout un tas
d'armes par destination et a commencé
par les boules de pétanque et donc on a
bien vu cette table présentée par les
forces de l'ordre avec tout cet attirail
et qui devait démontrer la violence des
manifestants mais en fait cette Razia de
matériel elle ne correspond pas
à la raziane matériel des gens qui
étaient la manifester pour manifester
mais bien les 24000 personnes et
véhicules qui ont été interpellés et
donc j'espère que vous êtes nombreux à
ne pas être tombé dans ce panneau là je
pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
tombés dans ce panneau là c'était bien
tendu mais moi faut que je retourne
chercher mes boules de pétanque à la
gendarmerie de Lezay et j'avais
clairement pas du tout l'intention d'en
faire usage sur qui que ce soit ça coûte
trop cher puis voilà c'est pas c'est no
os et il y a peu de temps on a un
camarade qui est passé devant la
juridiction parce qu'en effet s'était
rendu à la manifestation avec son camion
qui est aussi son qu'il est et la
grimpeur et la guerre et donc il voyage
avec son matériel et qu'est-ce qu'on
trouve dans un camion de grimpeur
Elagueur mais on trouve du matériel de
grimpeur et la guerre
vous plaît vous suit bien c'est par
conséquent tous les objets collectés qui
sont potentiellement des armes par
destination sont au fond comment dire le
fruit d'une stratégie volontaire des
forces de l'ordre pour abîmer l'image de
la manifestation du 25 mars
[Musique]
identité contrôle de véhicule après les
stratégies si vous qui voulez définissez
mais c'est factuel
ouais si je peux rajouter juste un
un petit village de vanzé ou ont
commencé les le premier rassemblement
autorisé sur une parcelle autorisée les
seuls cas en fait de de personnes plus
ou moins énervées que j'ai pu apercevoir
ce jour-là puisque je faisais j'étais au
bord de la route pour orienter les les
manifestants c'est c'est une personne en
véhiculé qui a accéléré violemment
devant nous pour nous montrer plutôt son
hostilité
c'est le seul le seul cas de
d'énervement voilà parmi les
manifestants il y avait plutôt de du
calme et de la bienveillance
d'accord donc les objets collectés c'est
une razzia organisée parmi les 24 000
personnes dont j'ai pas bien compris
c'est le vivait autour non non je vous
ai pas posé des questions et par contre
les personnes excitées vous avez pu
rencontrer était des personnes locales
qui n'étaient pas tout à fait satisfaite
de la tenue de cette manifestation ce
sera au compte-rendu et puis nous avons
une audition publique je pense que
chacun appréciera les arguments que vous
évoquez je voudrais en venir maintenant
à des éléments que vous
avez cité noté sur votre site Internet
alors pardonnez moi je dois aller
retrouver voilà
donc c'est le récit des événements tel
qu'il est publié sur votre site et je
vous confirme par conséquent nous le
consultons
il est écrit ceci on établissant un
fortin autour et dans le chantier de la
bassine
l'état-major de l'agendarmerie s'est
assuré une position défensive forte
position défensive forte
malgré tout nous avons pensé que si nous
parvenions jusqu'à la bassine
le nombre nous permettrait de l'ancien
clé
et que le pourtour serait émaillé
d'approche d'ordre diverses d'approches
d'ordre diverses champ est extrêmement
large ce qui aurait permis
éventuellement d'arracher de nouveaux
l'Église et de stopper au moins
temporairement les travaux pendant
quelques temps
en effet votre description nous sommes
correspondent au constat que nous avons
fait sur place c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une sorte de logique topographique du
site
dans la mesure où compte tenu à la fois
de la très forte visibilité sur le site
de cette très grande étendue
contenu aussi de ce que nous savons très
précisément pas simplement j'allais dire
cru sur parole les forces de l'ordre ça
me regardait les photographies y compris
celle publiée par des manifestants
contenus par conséquent de la
disposition des forces de l'ordre
en effet défensive entourant
l'infrastructure il nous apparaît que il
ne peut pas y avoir de l'affrontement
sur ce site si l'affrontement n'est pas
souhaité
il nous a parlé que de façon physique
géographique topographique disais-je il
n'y a pas de possibilité de contact avec
les forces de l'ordre de contact
physique
s'il n'y a pas volonté d'aller au
contact et il me semble que dans la
description que vous faites des
événements de la journée lorsque vous
notez à la fois la position défensive
forte des forces de l'ordre que vous
parlez de parvenir jusqu'à la bassine
pour
donner lieu à des approches d'ordre
diverses il me semble qu'en effet cela
note qu'il y avait une volonté de
contact avec les forces de l'ordre
qu'elle est le commentaire que vous
faites de cette appréciation que je
porte
mais sur la partager des précisions au
niveau factuel juste pour revenir sur le
point précédent sur la dissimilation et
le port d'équipement de protection par
des manifestants je tiens à rappeler le
cadre du droit international le droit
international le Pacte international
relatif au droit civil et politique
convention à laquelle du coup la France
est signataire elle est donc liée aussi
par ses obligations positives le simple
fait que des participants viennent avec
un équipement de protection comme des
masques à gaz ou des casques ça ne
permet pas de
présumer que ces participants oui
je n'ai pas parlé de masque je t'ai pas
parlé de capuche à aucun moment à aucun
moment peut-être que d'autres le front
ça n'est pas mon cas ce n'est pas le cas
non plus du président
je vous parle d'objets qui sont des
objets potentiellement comme étant armes
par destination donc faites pas dire ce
que je n'ai pas dit je n'ai pas parlé de
capuche je n'ai pas parlé d'éléments qui
serait vestimentairement discriminant ce
n'est pas mon sujet moi je parle des
leviers de violence voilà répondez à ce
point
sur sur les saisies qui ont lieu moi
j'ai pas de réponse à apporter par
contre sur le dispositif que vous
évoquiez ce fortin tel qu'on tel qu'on
l'a appelé nous ce qu'on a constaté
autour de la bassine c'est effectivement
ce dispositif de gendarmerie avec donc
ces 3000 gendarmes qui sont autour de la
bassine avec cette lignée de camion sur
le contact le contact qui a eu lieu
entre les manifestants et la gendarmerie
notre rapport et nos observations de
terrain montrent que le premier contact
qui a eu lieu entre les les manifestants
et la gendarmerie il se déroule à une
grande distance de la bassine il se
déroule à 1,4 km de la bassine il
intervient précisément à 12h35 on est au
sud d'Asnières à ce moment-là les
cortèges viennent de ce de se séparer il
y a un cortège bleu qui avance à travers
champ qui arrive au sud d'Asnières à ce
moment là précisément à 12h35 à 12h30 on
voit au loin la pm2i le peloton motorisé
d'intervention qui se déplace et qui
vient à ce moment-là les gendarmes
descendent dans le champ de leur quad et
de manière quasi concomitante il y a
deux tiers de chandelles romaines qui
sont faites par deux manifestants et là
directement les gendarmes répondent avec
un usage de gaz lacrymogène massif mais
qui va toucher tout le monde de manière
indiscriminée et après les gendarmes
repartent se remettent sur leur quad et
vont venir au contact directement des
cortèges roses et jaunes ces cortèges
roses et jaunes ils sont à grandes
distances ils tirent depuis leur quad à
grande distance là encore sur des
personnes qui ne présentent pas de
danger pour les gendarmes il y a un
usage de gaz lacrymogène qui est qui est
fait de manière indiscriminée sur des
gens qui sont à grande distance et ce
que nous disent les rapports de l'iggn
et de la préfecture des Deux-Sèvres il
ne raconte pas du tout l'effet de la
même manière
la préfète elle affirme à tort que
l'usage de la force a été décidé au vu
des premières attaques contre la
gendarmerie sous la forme de cocktail
Molotov et de tirs tendu de mortier
d'artifice nous à 12h35 j'y étais
précisément sur place au sud dernière à
1,4 km de la bassine
on ne voit pas de cocktail Molotov à ce
moment là on nous dit aussi qu'il y a eu
des sommations juste avant on entend
strictement aucune sommation ça c'est
sur l'effet sur le premier contact qui a
eu lieu entre la gendarmerie et les
manifestants il a eu lieu bien loin de
la bassine à 1,4 km et les tirs se sont
faits de manière indiscriminée sur
l'ensemble des personnes qui étaient
présentes sur les ensembles des cortèges
et ce qui est ce qui est drôle c'est que
dans les rapports de l'hygiène de la
préfecture des Deux-Sèvres sur ce qui
s'est passé sur les cortèges roses et
jaunes qui sont parfaitement pacifiques
il n'y a pas strictement pas eu
d'attaque qui sont à grande distance et
d'ailleurs aussi vous avez l'émission de
complément d'enquête qui montre
parfaitement à ce moment là que les pm2i
viennent étirent et qu'apparemment ils
méconnent aussi un ordre directement du
commandant et tire sur un cortège
Pacifique les rapports officiels qui
vont sont présentés ne font strictement
aucune mention de ces faits je vous
remercie
observé autour de la bassine sur cette
zone des 100 m
nous nous faisons le constat je le
répète géographique compte tenu des
distances à parcourir pour atteindre les
forces de l'ordre qui a même son
statique et défensive il faut par
conséquent une volonté de les atteindre
dans la bande des 100 mètres en réalité
autour des forces de l'ordre c'est là
que les affrontements sur les plus
violents est-ce que quels sont les
commentaires que vous avez à faire par
rapport à cette assez constat que nous
avons pu faire sur place
les constats qu'on a pu faire sur place
effectivement on voyait des groupes de
de manifestants qui s'avançaient vers la
bassine et qui essayait de progresser
mais l'autre constat qu'on a fait aussi
c'est que à ce moment-là
toute la bande des 100 m en fait et
noyer sous les gaz il faut bien imaginer
quand l'espace de deux heures il y a
5000 grenades qui ont été tirés grenades
lacrymogène et d'ailleurs il n'est même
pas précisé combien de grenades j'aime
de zèle ont été ont été tirés en
l'espace de ces deux heures il faut bien
se représenter que ça fait près d'une
grenade toutes les deux secondes et donc
à ce moment là la zone elle est
complètement noyée sous les gaz il y a
des détonations parfois on imagine que
ça ne que c'est de la gm2l elles sont
très rapprochées c'est des donations et
elles vise ses
usages de la force ils vivent de manière
indiscriminée toutes les personnes qui
sont présentes autour de la bassine
qu'elles soient à proximité directe et
là il y a sans en effet une nécessité
d'usage de la force à ce moment-là mais
qu'elle soit aussi bien au delà en fait
de la bassine et qu'elle ne présente
strictement aucun danger pour les
gendarmes il y a eu des dispositifs à
propulsion enfin retard qui ont été
utilisés pour lancer ces gaz
lacrymogènes soit à 50 sans ou 200 m et
donc les tirs en fait on était effectués
partout sur zone pour noyer l'espace de
gaz de lacrymogène et ici vous avez pas
de distinction qui est faite entre des
personnes qui seraient violentes des
manifestants pacifiques des blessés des
journalistes des observateurs et viser
de manière indiscriminée l'ensemble des
personnes sur la zone ce n'est pas un
usage qui soit ni nécessaire ni
proportionné de la force
pardon je me permets juste comme on est
sur cette ces éléments de topographie et
encore une fois en reprenant les
éléments que vous mentionnez sur sur
votre site internet
vous vous précisez un moment donné que
l'objectif c'est d'arracher les grilles
et de stopper les travaux donc là
comment dire on est sur une une volonté
de te faire en sorte que le chantier ne
puisse pas se poursuivre c'est bien cela
je crois que je vais être assez à l'aise
pour répondre à cette question depuis
deux ans des travaux ont démarré à Mozet
et ses travaux sont toujours sous le
coup d'une décision de justice qui doit
tomber au tribunal administratif de
Bordeaux et qui peut-être en bout de
chaîne viendra dire l'illégalité de ses
ouvrages et donc face à ce refus de
l'État d'attendre que tout le droit soit
dit l'état pousse y compris les porteurs
de projets à accélérer la démarche comme
actuellement où il y a une vraie
pression pour que la Coop de l'eau fasse
très rapidement prière phase très
rapidement et pas et ça va pas du tout
dans le sens de l'apaisement nous je
rappelle qu'on demande un moratoire et
c'est vraiment au vu de cette décision
là et de cette réalité juridique là
qu'on demande un moratoire et c'est pour
ça qu'on est rentré en désobéissance
civile c'est parce qu'on a vraiment le
sentiment quand des pies et on vous a
fait dans le propos liminaire l'étendue
de tout ce qu'on a développé pour être
entendu dans le cadre démocratique et en
dépit de ça on se retrouve vraiment avec
le sentiment qu'on a un état et un
gouvernement qui
qu'on a démonté collectivement accroche
à banc qu'il s'agit d'ouvrage illégaux
et s'ils ne le sont pas encore ils le
sont des signals de venir et
complètement à l'envers de l'histoire
c'est que ces ouvrages sont des ouvrages
écossidaires et face à l'inaction du
gouvernement ou à la complicité de
certaines collectivités locales et bien
on a décidé de s'opposer et y compris à
nos corps
à nos corps défendant
que vous enfin donc à partir de là
comment dire vous formulez l'hypothèse
puisque vous vous dites que ils seront
illégaux donc vous excentez vous
formulez l’hypothèse qu'ils le sont et
que c'est ce qui le justifie ça très
concrètement la plupart des ouvrages qui
ont été visés revendiquées
collectivement etc et des ouvrages
illégaux voilà et ensuite on le redit et
puis alors c'est vrai qu'ici c'est
peut-être pas évident mais on a vraiment
tous les faisceaux au niveau tribunal
administratif qui disent qu'on va on va
gagner à la fin déjà les trois premières
décisions en première instance à
Poitiers on dit que il fallait modifier
les arrêter donc le premier arrêté ça a
été pour dire il y a trop de bassines il
en faut 16 deuxième arrêté ça a été pour
dire elles sont trop grandes donc
troisième arrêté et aujourd'hui on dit
ben en fait les conditions de
remplissage elles sont pas compatibles
avec la loi directive sur l'eau on
autorise le remplissage des bassines
alors même que la rivière mignon
contrebas est à sec en plein hiver donc
évidemment que là on a l'exemple
flagrant d'un non respect des directives
européennes et nous au niveau de
territoire qui nous est cher le vrai
sentiment que les collectivités les
institutions ne font pas le boulot c'est
ça qui nous met en chemin
j'en reviens aux éléments factuels qui
sont l'objet de la Commission dans quel
deux dernières questions à poser
monsieur le Président je m'en excuse par
avance auprès des collègues mais je j'ai
un rapport à rédiger je vous rappelle et
donc j'ai besoin d'avoir des réponses à
certaines questions que nous nous posons
et parfois affront renversé
avant dernière question
vous avez dit Madame Pasquier mais
chacun peut répondre
qu'il n'y a pas de distinction à faire
entre des individus qui seraient venus
là pour casser et venus qui venaient là
pour défendre une cause est-ce que
toutefois vous avez pu peut-être
monsieur greffe pourra-t-il répondre en
tant qu'observateur est-ce que vous avez
observé des actes de violence
j'allais dire déterminer volontaire
engagé de la part d'un certain nombre
d'individu présent dans le rassemblement
oui en tant que en tant qu'observateur
évidemment on était 18 sur le terrain on
a couvert une large zone oui il y avait
des gens qui jetaient des projectiles y
compris des projectiles incendiaires on
a tous vu les camions en feu mais en
aucun cas le fait que quelques personnes
un groupe de personnes en tout cas
soient violent à l'encontre des forces
de l'ordre ne justifie un tel usage qui
soit disproportionné et indiscriminés
sur l'ensemble de la zone de la force à
l'encontre de l'ensemble des
manifestants qui étaient présents sur
zone et même bien loin puisque les
dispositifs qui ont été utilisés je le
rappelle c'était des dispositifs qui
permettaient de lancer des grenades
lacrymogènes à plus de 200 mètres à plus
de 200 mètres il n'y a strictement aucun
danger pour les forces de l'ordre ni
même pour la bassine donc oui nous avons
vu ces individus violents pour autant on
a constaté que la réponse qui a été
faite ne rentrait pas dans le cadre de
de strict nécessité et de strict
proportionnalité
et quel était quel était selon vous le
monsieur Legay pourra répondre également
quel était selon vous le profil de ces
individus que vous avez constaté sur
place
pour constater ce qu'on voit moi ce que
ce que j'ai vu c'est des individus qui
jettent qui qui jettent des projectiles
je peux pas vous en dire plus en fait
sur le sur le profil des personnes un
figure de points figure dans le rapport
que vous avez rédigé
évidemment on a tout mentionné dans le
rapport qui était qui était rédigé et
vous verrez cette évoqué on évoque les
Gets projectiles les jets de cocktail
Molotov on évoque les camions qui sont
en feu nous nous mettons aucun fait nous
on se place sur le temps long pas sur le
temps médiatique ce rapport il y a 18
observateurs qui étaient présents sur le
terrain ce rapport on a mis trois mois à
le construire car chaque équipe
d'observation fait des minutiers précis
minutes par minute de ce qu'il se
déroule après on a repris les positions
de chacune des équipes pour croiser les
informations on a des photos on a des
vidéos et après quand on souhaitait même
corroborer des faits on a aussi pris des
sources extérieures mais principalement
nous nous travaillons avec notre propre
matériel donc sur l'effet et sur ce qui
s'est déroulé bien évidemment nous
n'avons omis aucun fait de ce que nous
avons pu constater sur place
je vous remercie
[Musique]
comment dire le les violences sont les
avis et vous le savez elles ont été de
Paris d'autres et une des éléments forts
qui nous emmènent devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est l'audition de certains
passants avant nous et qui venaient à
remettre en cause la réalité des
blessures infligées à nos camarades et
donc j'espère que dans vos questions et
dans l'espace de temps qui nous est
offert là pour faire le point sur ce qui
s'est passé à Sainte Soline on aura
l'occasion d'entendre Jérémy qui puisse
vous faire état de l'ensemble qui ait
aucun doute sur la réalité des blessures
infligées à Sainte Soline de part et
d'autre mais le bilan il est
complètement déséquilibré et donc si ce
bilan est déséquilibré c'est que la
violence et les armes pour la créer
était également des équilibrés dans les
déclarations de Monsieur Rodriguez qui
osent prétendre qu'un des éléments qui
fait qu'il y a eu autant de répondant
c'est qu'on était il sentait qu'on était
plus équipés que lui
c'est évidemment un mensongeéonté
si on devait faire l'état comparatif des
de l'attirail ramené par un camp et par
l'autre il y aurait évidemment pas photo
c'est une un affrontement
inégal très clairement le matériel de
protection etc et très clairement le
bilan humain doit
alors il y a plusieurs questions qui
vous occupent et qui nous occupent aussi
c'est comment on en est arrivé là et ce
qui doit tous nous préoccuper c'est
comment on fait en sorte que ça ne se
reproduise pas il faut que dans
l'histoire de France cette opération de
maintien de l'ordre à Sainte Soline soit
vécu comme un véritable échec collectif
y compris des forces de l'ordre ce n'est
pas ça ne peut pas constituer une
nouvelle doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
que de tout baser sur le maintien dans
les grandes profondeurs c'est des
éléments techniques qu'on retrouve dans
la voie du gendarme ou dans les
expressions des des états majors en fait
technique qui consiste et qu'on je vais
dans nos chairs de bombarder à 200
mètres tout militant tout manifestants
en partant du principe que puisqu'il a
une réunion interdite de base on peut
tous permettre sur son corps quel que
soit son corps que ce soit un enfant
quel que soit le comportement adopté et
c'est ce qui a généré la boucherie de
sainte Soline et c'était dans ces
termes-là qu'il faudra retenir cette
histoire sainte Soline c'est aussi
honteux pour la gendarmerie que la mort
de Rémi Fraisse c'est aussi honteux que
la mort des manifestants comme Vidal
Michalon c'est des choses qui font que
justement la doctrine n'est pas adaptée
tout à l'heure je l'avais envie de
réagir justement à cette notion de
contact moi je fais plein de manifs on
était au contact avec les forces de
l'ordre ils étaient au contact et donc
on discutait aussi et le rapport de
force il se passait avec les gradés et
avec les consignes qu'on pouvait donner
quand on nous interdit et moi petite
personnelle je suis interdit de venir en
manifestations je suis sous le coup d'un
contrôle judiciaire
protéger cette fonction aussi dans le
collectif d'être un interlocuteur
identifié par les forces de l'ordre
comme quelqu'un avec qui on peut
discuter ou et bien on nous interdisant
tout ça en nous interditant également
dans nos manifestations de venir avec
tout autre matériel d'organisation de
manifestations toutes nos manifs elles
ont toujours été pilotées par un
tracteur pour dire haut et fort que
c'est une lutte dépaysant et des
habitants contre l'agro-industrie quand
on nous enlève par des arrêtés
préfectoraux la possibilité de piloter
nos cortèges avec ces tracteurs on nous
empêche nos moyens d'agir et en effet
ces arrêtés arbitraires et liberticides
génèrent pour nous une impossibilité de
maintenir le rapport de force c'est
évident quand il y a 30 000 personnes
d'un côté 4000 de l'autre sur armée de
cette manière-là tout le stress on est
sur des moments très fragiles mais si la
seule réponse de prise de contact c'est
d'envoyer le ponton de quad vous
comprendrez que comme premier contact
c'est pas une bonne base et certainement
que vous avez là à travers ce fait des
cris dans le rapport de la LDH le fait
que par la suite bien la manifestation
est pris ce tour là et que parmi les
manifestants il y a peut-être même des
gens qui avaient pas du tout prévu de
s'opposer aux forces de l'ordre et qu'il
a dans un réflexe de survie se sont
retrouvés à devoir le faire comme par
exemple des élus en écharpe ont dû
s'interposer physiquement pour que des
blessés dans un état grave
puissent ne plus être la cible de tir de
LBD sur ces fameux quads vous connaissez
la polémique là-dessus j'espère que vous
aurez l'occasion de poser la question à
Monsieur Darmanin pour cette succession
de mensonges qu'il a proféré dans les
médias sur des éléments très ponctuels
très très factuels comme le tir des LBD
ou d'abord uni sur l'irréalité de des
blessures chez nous et cetera et cetera
je passe la parole à Monsieur Mendes
s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs
on va essayer de
revenir sur deux trois points en plus de
ce que l'intime c'est le rapporteur
parce que malgré l'interdiction
préfectorale de manifester le recours
contre cette décision qui a été rejeté
devant la justice administrative ce que
vous avez confirmé à nouveau au début de
votre intervention vous avez maintenu
l'appel à manifester et l'organisation
de cet événement qui a connu les
événements et les deux rendements qu'on
connaît nous sommes en train de débattre
juste pour rappel 62 couteaux 67 boules
de pétanque cet artifice si bidons
d'essence 12 pierres et parpaing 13 age
et machette 5 matraques ou battent de
baseball 20 euros seul bonbonnes de gaz
69 équipement de protection 95 au Titi
hiver qui sont des armes par destination
et 2 tonnes de pierre qui avait été mise
de côté d'après Ouest-France 6 tonnes
pardon de Pierre Miss de côté d'après
Ouest-France qui était sur place et qui
relatait en direct les événements je
prends ce qui est noté les loutres
jaunes dit les plus radicalisés ce que
vous avez parlé des cortèges jaune rose
et je ne sais plus la troisième couleur
radicacée comptait directement à
l'attaque des forces de l'ordre c'est le
journaliste qui l'écrit ce n'est pas
Gérald Darmanin ce n'est pas nous c'est
le journaliste qui l'a constaté de
lui-même et qui dit les plus radicalisés
sont partis directement au contact des
forces de l'ordre est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur ce sujet et
pourquoi justement avoir fait trois
types de cortèges un qui a l'air de
rentrer en direct contre les forces de
l'ordre et deux autres qui avaient l'air
de contourner pour rentrer sur eux un
secteur totalement interdit à l'accès le
les convois massifs qui viennent de
plusieurs villes dans sur les boucs
télégrammes sur Twitter et sur votre
site internet on lit mise en place de
minibus nous expliquer le financement
peut-être de ces minibus c'est
intéressant pour nous parce qu'on
cherche aussi à savoir comment sont
financés ce genre d'événements et sur le
non respect à plusieurs reprises vous
nous dites depuis tout à l'heure que
tout ça c'est pour protéger du covid et
d'autres je pense que la batte de
baseball c'est pas trop le cas mais ce
qui est noté dans les différents
documents qu'on retrouve sur vos books
de télégram que vous partagez sur
Internet et sur Twitter et sur Twitter
c'est que il faut se protéger de la
police ne pas répondre à la police ne
pas donner son identité couper son
numéro de téléphone en fait tout ce
qu'il faut pour entre guillemets faire
en sorte que les relations avec la
gendarmerie et la police soit de
mauvaise qualité donc pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi vous cherchez
absolument cette confrontation
il y a plusieurs questions dans la
question je vais pas répondre à tout
notamment puisque vous en êtes rendu
compte en posant la question il y a tout
un tas de questions qui sont directement
en lien avec l'organisation de sainte
Soline sur le plan logistique qui sont
exactement les raisons pour laquelle je
comparer devant le tribunal si vous
pouvez juste vous éloigner voilà pardon
devant le tribunal de Niort donc on vous
a fait état des certain nombre de
réserves et il y a tout un pan de
questions auxquelles on ne va pas
répondre
après ben vous revenez sur ce butin
récolté pendant je rappelle les 24000
contrôles si 13h dans 24000 contrôles de
sur un territoire il y a des gens qui
font du bois ça vous paraît une grande
je ne sais pas je vous y revenais mais
très factuellement et venez faire
l'enquête à Amel et venez voir mais en
plus c'est facile parce que le matériel
on peut aller le rechercher derrière
donc ça ça s'instruit si vous voulez
savoir à quoi elles servaient les boules
ben venez boire un coup à mail et puis
venez voir avec les gens qui se sont
fait je vais leur matériel donc j'y
reviens pour les sitton de cailloux ça
me fait bien rire les cailloux chez nous
il y a qu'à se baisser pour les trouver
puisqu'il n'y a plus de sol puisqu'il
n'y a plus de matière organique et donc
on vit sur des sols qui sont
complètement lessivés donc je pense que
c'est une information qui est flouée je
vois vraiment pas l'intérêt stratégique
à aucun niveau à brasser 6 kilos de
cailloux
si tonnes de 6 tonnes de caillou et
ensuite par rapport à votre question sur
l'organisation de minibus c'est
peut-être un logiciel que vous avez plus
à RM ça s'appelle l'autogestion
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur
bellamyti
je faisais j'abordais les loutres jaunes
donc que vous n'avez pas abordé et le
fait de pourquoi vous allez être rentré
sur trois types de convois différents
alors que un seul aurait pu servir vu
que de toute façon tout était interdit
et vous n'avez pas répondu cette partie
de l'interdiction non plus pour avoir
maintenu quand même cette manifestation
de cette manière là Monsieur exactement
les éléments pour lesquels je comparer
monsieur greffe vous souhaitiez
intervenir
oui c'était pour vous répondre sur le
contact avec les cortèges jaunes et rose
je viens de vous le dire et vous pourrez
aller voir notre rapport qui est basé du
coup sur les observations de 18
observateurs qui étaient présents sur le
terrain les le premier contact avec les
cortège rose et jaune et d'ailleurs
aussi vous pourrez aller voir l'émission
de complément d'enquête puisque c'est
très visible à ce moment là à moins de
tordre la réalité ce premier contact
il intervient loin de la bassine et les
forces de l'ordre tirent à distance à ce
moment-là de manière assez forte plein
de gaz lacrymogènes sur ces personnes
qui ne sont même pas au contact des
forces de l'ordre à ce moment là il n'y
a strictement aucun contact entre les
gendarmes et le cortège rose et jaune
les gendarmes prennent la décision de
tirer sur ces deux cortèges alors qu'il
ne présente strictement aucun danger
pour eux et ils tirent à grande distance
de ces cortèges
monsieur benamiti je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs je voudrais vous interroger
sur les liens
entre votre organisation et les partis
politiques qui vous soutiennent qui vous
ont soutenues et dont certains élus
parfois de notre assemblée
ont pu participer à
la manifestation qui fait l'objet de
cette commission aux manifestations qui
font l'objet de cette commission je
voudrais savoir si en amont de la
manifestation
en question il y a eu des contacts
resserrés si oui de quelle nature avec
les organisations politiques en question
dont je rappelle que les photos y
compris sont dans le rapport que nous
transmettez
et quelles ont été la nature de ces
échanges sur la présentation des risques
sur le partage
des modalités d'organisation de
coordination de cet événement je crois
que certains d'entre vous d'ailleurs été
candidats ce qui est tout à fait votre
bras d'ailleurs à des élections
soutenues par des organisations
politiques qui soutiennent et qui ont
soutenu et qui a été présentes lors de
ces manifestations comment comment vous
fonctionnez avec les partis politiques
en question est-ce qu'il y a des liens
logistiques est-ce qu'il y a des liens
financiers au-delà des liens humains
évidents que nous pouvons observer y
compris dans votre appart je remercie
je veux bien répondre
il y a aucun souci là-dessus à chaque
fois qu'on organise une manifestation il
y a un appel à manifestation et on
l'envoie à toutes les organisations qui
nous ont soutenu au moins une fois et en
leur sein avec leur fonctionnement
démocratique propre il décide de s'y
réassocier ou pas et donc nous on est
toujours dans l'optique où jusqu'à
preuve du contraire donc une
manifestation et pas interdite mal est
autorisé donc toutes ces organisations
là elles se joignent à une manifestation
et dans l'espoir qu'elle ne soit pas
interdite et voilà c'est comme ça qu'on
se retrouve en effet avec une partie
c'est vrai que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas encore eu de député de la lrem qui
est venu nous soutenir et pourtant
puisqu'il est question d'intérêt général
vous devriez nous accompagner on est
prêt à vous faire un tour de terrain et
c'est évident qu'à la fin de ce tour de
terrain vous serez des nôtres vous aurez
compris pourquoi c'est inacceptable
pourquoi on s'oppose à tel point et donc
on est dans le jeu tout à fait classique
et moi j'ai envie de dire
bravo et merci aux élus qui siègent et
qui viennent sur ces manifestations
parce que là pour le coup on a vraiment
le sentiment qui sont à leur place ce
qu'on attendait lui à savoir des
représentants du peuple à savoir les
gens qui sont à l'écoute de nos
préoccupations et qui sont même parfois
capables de s'engager physiquement pour
sauver des blessés
donc je les remercie ici infiniment et
citoyennement parlant et Jeanne vous
invite cordialement à la prochaine
je
trouve que le terme autogestion est
vraiment extraordinaire il s'applique
chaque organisation et personne qui veut
s'investir à venir sur un rassemblement
tel qu'il est les gens se débrouillent
entre eux oui c'est intéressant ça comme
ça comme fonctionnement
non j'ai pris dans l'ordre donc je vous
en prie merci monsieur le Président du
coup moi je vous remercie d'être venu du
coup aujourd'hui devant nous pour
répondre à la fois à nos questions mais
aussi témoigner de de ce qu'il s'est
passé et de aussi l'origine de vos
engagements moi ce que j'observe et au
fur et à mesure des de ces auditions
quand même je tiens à ce que ça soit
souligné c'est qu'il y a un fil rouge en
tout cas dans les mobilisations et dans
ce qu'on peut entendre nous en audition
c'est les impasses démocratiques
auxquels nous sommes confrontés dans
notre pays et quand on fait le lien
entre ce que vous avez pu nous dire avec
toutes les processus judiciaires qui ont
été qui ont été en cours et le fait que
par exemple des bassines soient
illégales dans plein de situations on le
fait que quand on a analysé ce qui s'est
passé au moment des mobilisations
retraite avec une bascule qu'on a tous
observé le soir du 49-3 moi je tiens à
souligner voilà cet aspect de l'impasse
démocratique et qui est le pas de la
responsabilité des personnes qui se
mobilisent pour des causes à défendre
qu'elle soit psychologique ou au jeu de
niveau social mais du de la
responsabilité des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui soit au gouvernement ou soit
qui en tout cas qui dirige ce pays moi
je voulais vous entendre parce que je
pense que c'est un élément essentiel
vous en avez parlé sur la question du
coup humain c'est d'ailleurs le titre du
rapport qui a été fait par les
observateurs c'est ce que nous on avait
constaté effectivement sur le terrain
Sainte-Soline c'était le quoi qu'il en
coûte humain de ce maintien de l'ordre
et je pense que c'est important qu'on
puisse avoir accès à l'ampleur des
blessures et je j'aimerais bien vous
interroger là-dessus et une deuxième
question si on en a le temps mais c'est
aussi quelles sont vos préconisations
aussi pour pouvoir quelle est la sortie
de crise en fait parce que vous avez
très bien décrits une situation qui
s'enlise avec des recours avec la
lenteur de tout ça et des projets qui
avancent malgré la justice qui me
demande justement des arrêts et qu'elle
pète justement l'issue en fait sur la
lutte vis-à-vis des mégas bassines je
vous remercie
je vais parler des blessés
d'abord dire que à titre personnel
j'étais extrêmement choqué parce qu'il
s'est passé moi j'étais à Mel donc loin
de la situation
et j'ai reçu tous les coups de fil enfin
beaucoup de coups de fil de personnes
sur place en grande difficulté en
particulier quand on a compris que le
SAMU était en difficulté pour intervenir
sur les blessures d'abord on moi
j'aurais aimé avoir aussi un état des
lieux des blessures des forces de
l'ordre parce que on les regrette
également en tout cas je pense que tout
le monde les regrette je peux parler
comme un nom mais on les regrette il a
été évoqué 40 blessés je crois
un certain nombre de blessés sont de
blessures sont été déclarées le
lendemain il me semble que c'était des
acouphènes donc je pense qu'il y a aussi
tout un tas de blessures qui sont liées
à
la puissance des armes qui sont
utilisées
sans parler de la souffrance psychique
des policiers aussi qui doit être réel
puisque en fait je suppose qu'ils ont
pas fait ce métier pour faire ce qu'on
leur a demandé de faire ce jour-là du
côté des manifestants nous on a dénombré
200 blessés on a un tableau là que l'on
peut vous mettre à disposition qui
s'arrête à 355 parce qu'en fait le
compte c'était pas du tout notre
objectif ça s'est fait comme ça et donc
on a on a cette liste là avec des
détails de plaid etc
sur ces 200 blessés il y en a une
quarantaine qui sont très graves et
trois qui étaient en urgence absolue
moi je suis surpris qui est pas eu de
décès à Sainte Soline je pense que s'il
y a pas eu deux décès à Sainte solide au
moins c'est
grâce à l'organisation à l'autorisation
des médicaments
de compenser d'une façon qui me surprend
toujours en tant que médecin
ce retard d'intervention
et je suis
très agréablement surpris par
l'évolution de l'état de santé de Serge
d en particulier même si les dernières
nouvelles qui qui sont sortis concernant
son état sont quand même très
inquiétants puisque il a eu une
intervention pour remplacer le morceau
d'os qui a été enlevé qui a dû être
enlevé pour le sauver il a ce morceau
était remplacé par une pièce fabriquée
avec des imprimantes 3D c'est une
technique classique en neurochirurgie
malheureusement il a pas supporté cette
greffe il a eu des surinfections et il a
dû à nouveau être opéré pour que ce
greffon soit enlevé donc il est à
nouveau sans greffon c'est à dire qu'il
a
on a vu la photo du petit ID là Eddy qui
voilà c'est exactement le même type de
situation
dans ce dernier communiqué que je vous
invite à lire si vous l'avez pas fait
il est précisé que il a passé trois
semaines en dehors de l'hôpital depuis
les manifestations
ce qui n'est pas beaucoup
le je voudrais juste insister sur une
toute petite chose que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé de 100
mètres et en effet on a l'impression que
dans une proximité avec cette position
de Fortin qui avait le la gendarmerie il
y a un danger qui est majeur au fur et à
mesure qu'on s'approche et on imagine
que sans mettre est une zone dangereuse
et que 50 m est encore plus en réalité
ce qu'on a observé c'est que c'était pas
100 m c'était 200 m et on a eu vu
beaucoup de blessures qui étaient dans
ce périmètre où les gens pensaient
qu'ils étaient même s'ils étaient en
effet sur une zone de manifestation
interdite etc ils étaient dans une zone
ils étaient pas aussi en danger qu'ils
le pensait or ils étaient dans un danger
massif d'une part par la pluie de de
grenade qui leur tombait dessus et aussi
par des tirements conformes en tout cas
à la conformité douteuse puisque en fait
il y a des questions sur le langue de
tir
alors qu'est-ce qu'un tiers tendu
qu'est-ce qu'un tiers non tendu je pense
que c'est je sais pas définir ça mais
voilà et le dernier point sur lequel il
me paraît important d'insister c'est que
[Musique]
en profondeur qui sont arrivés à Mel
pour avoir un autre avis
donc il y a cette première chose là mais
il y a aussi nombre de chocs qui
traversent et qui peut expliquer un
certain nombre de lésions sur lequel je
vais pas m'étendre parce que il y a
aussi l'excision de secret médical mais
en tout cas on a vu des lésions 220 je
pense qu'il y a vraiment une
une
un angle mort sur cet aspect là et le
dernier point c'est le la manifestation
du 1er mai à Paris qui donc sort des du
cadre de cette commission d'enquête mais
où on a eu un blessé très grave chez les
forces de l'ordre et un gilet de
cocktail Molotov sur les forces de
l'ordre c'est pas la même personne qui
reçoit le cocktail Molotov et qui est
blessé gravement je sais pas si c'est un
élément qui éclaire pour les personnes
de la commission
le la personne qui est blessé grièvement
est blessée par une grenade à SSD il me
semble qui est lancé de façon non
conforme par un de ses collègues et qui
produit une explosion dans le coup de du
gendarme qui est pourtant très très bien
protégé et qui semble-t-il aurait mais
je n'ai pas de certitude là-dessus une
triple fracture cervicale et j'imagine
un pronostic fonctionnel très difficile
moi personnellement c'est pour ça que je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour témoigner
de la dangerosité de ces armes et me
semble-t-il de la nécessité des
interdire
qu'elles explosent ou que il s'agit des
LBD ou plus récemment des tirs de
l'utilisation d'armes type bin bag ou
autre chose comme ça voilà merci
sur sur les blessés j'aimerais aussi
vous faire part de nos constats en tant
qu'observateur
personnel moi aussi je fais j'ai
participé à beaucoup de manifestations
et c'est vrai que j'étais très choqué en
revenant sur place j'ai vu une personne
qui avait l'oeil totalement éclaté j'ai
vu des chairs ouvertes avec du sang
j'aimerais revenir sur un moment précis
de la manifestation entre 13h41 et 14h03
celui du gazage des blessés et je vous
renverrai à notre rapport et à la
lecture du rapport sur le déroulé précis
des faits que que je vais vous faire
à ce moment là il y a une chaîne d'élus
qui est identifiée et des manifestants
calmes qui s'est formé pour protéger des
blessés qui attendaient les secours sur
une route près de la bassine mais on
n'est pas du tout en fait sur le lieu à
proximité de la bassine un peu à l'écart
parmi ces blessés il y a notamment deux
blessés graves il y a deux équipes
d'observation qui était là pour
documenter la situation à ce moment
elles ont pu observer que le pm2i donc
le peloton d'intervention et gendarmes
qui étaient sur les quad donc tirer des
grenades de manière indiscriminée
généralisée sur toute la zone en visant
les blessés les élus et les manifestants
qui les protégés une équipe
d'observation qui était placée aussi un
peu en retrait et parfaitement
identifiable ainsi que une journaliste
qui était présent à côté d'eux ont été
même visés par les tirs juste tirer sur
des personnes blessées au sens de la
jurisprudence de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ça s'appelle un
traitement inhumain et dégradant
le problème qu'on a concernant ce moment
c'est l'absence de documentation dans
les rapports officiels
la préfète elle n'a pas répondu elle
semblait confondre des événements avec
d'autres moments de l'évacuation des
blessés elle a fait mention d'une
agression des gendarmes par les
manifestants avec des engins
incendiaires les équipes qui étaient sur
place à ce moment-là elle ne constate
l'utilisation d'aucun engin incendiaire
le problème que nous rencontrons aussi
avec cette partie de l'intervention
puisqu'elle est même pas mentionnée dans
les différents rapports rapports de la
préfecture et rapport de la gendarmerie
le rapport de la préfecture des
Deux-Sèvres du coup qui a été publié
donc le 27 mars ne fait pas mention de
cet événement et quand on rapporte de la
gendarmerie qui a été publié le même
jour il ne fait même pas non plus
apparaître la chronologie de
l'intervention du pn2i entre 13h41 et
14h03 alors que toutes les autres
interventions du pm2i bien plus brève
quand elle sont notées
et j'aimerais aussi vous faire part de
ce deuxième moment concernant les
blessés et lui plus grave encore par
rapport à la constatation des faits que
je vais vous évoquer
les faits que je vous évoquais ce sont
ceux bien évidemment de l'entrave au
secours dont on a pu beaucoup parler
à ce moment là
c'est fait interviennent durant la phase
dite de trêve et je vous renverrai à la
partie de notre rapport sur la période
de trêve entre 14h08 et 15 heures 08 qui
est documenté dans notre rapport
alors déjà sur ce point il faut préciser
que la version officielle qui a été
présenté à les fausses et au demeurant
elle est incohérente dans les rapports
de la gendarmerie la trêve elle est
indiquée à partir de 14h20 dans le
rapport de la préfecture des Deux-Sèvres
elle est indiquée à 14h30
cette rectification elle est très
importante et elle nous permet
d'affirmer sans doute possible que la
zone était calme durant une heure
jusqu'à 15h08
les phases précédentes et notamment
l'usage à grande intensité de grenades
explosive peu avant la trêve ont
occasionné de très nombreuses bonnes
blessures sur au moins 200 personnes
dont certaines mutilées et trois
personnes en urgence absolue
parmi elles
Serge d blessé à 13h45 était en
situation de détresse vitale et a fait
l'objet de l'entrave au secours que nous
avons pu constater
dès 14h11 le SAMU contacté à indiquer
nos pouvoirs intervenir ce qui a
continué d'être le cas au fil des appels
durant toute leur
nous avons pu vérifier directement sur
le terrain et Amel que le SAMU puis les
pompiers déclarait ne pas pouvoir
parvenir aux personnes blessées il
ressort de ces échanges que l'équipe de
commandement n'avait pas donné
l'autorisation d'intervenir
au vu de la gravité de l'état de Serge D
et des premières réactions face à
l'entrave au secours les autorités ont
cherché avec constance ici à tromper le
public tant le ministre de l'Intérieur
la préfète des Deux-Sèvres le
commandement de la gendarmerie que la
direction du Samu de Niort les autorités
ont d'abord invoqué des heures dans la
zone où se trouvait le blessé s'agissant
de la période de trêve la zone a été
entièrement calme et de plus située à
200 mètres au nord-ouest du dispositif
de gendarmerie entourant la bassine et à
400 mètres de l'ensemble des
manifestants qui s'étaient rassemblés
pour une sorte de pique-nique nous
n'avons à ce moment là nous les
observateurs présents sur le terrain
constaté aucun obstacle à l'intervention
des secours de la part des manifestants
en très petits nombres aux côtés du
blessé où nous nous trouvions
les autorités après ont pu appuyer sur
le fait que des médecins militaires
avaient été dépêchés auprès de Serge D
le rapport de gendarmerie met en avant
une prise en charge à 14h37 nous qui
étions sur place avons constaté leur
arrivée à 14h57
ils ont pu accéder sans heure au blessés
et n'ayant pas le matériel adapté ont
attendu les soignants bénévoles qui
entouraient déjà Serge d l'arrivée du
Samu à 15h05
les autorités ont mis en avant un risque
d'hostilité à l'égarder ce cours à
l'inverse nous avons plutôt constaté que
face au risque d'interpellation lors de
la précédente par exemple manifestation
de sainte Soline les personnes
convoquées puis condamner ont
semble-t-il pour la plupart étaient
interpellés après avoir été contrôlé en
tant que personne blessée
et enfin les autorités ont avancé une
localisation incertaine et imprécise des
blessés alors qu'un hélicoptère
survolait en permanence la manifestation
et qu'elles auraient dû prévoir des
solutions adaptées pour permettre aux
blessés un accès aux soins effectifs ce
qui est possible y compris après la fin
de la trêve et de la levée des barrages
de gendarmerie
ces arguments tout comme ceux de la zone
d'exclusion qui au passage n'a
strictement aucune existence juridique
font ne doivent pas faire oublier que
ici les autorités publiques ont choisi
de ne pas se courir des blessés des
personnes blessées en détresse vitale
cela entre en contradiction avec les
obligations positives qui leur
répondaient et engage à notre sens leur
responsabilité
nous pouvons ignorer qu'un déploiement
des forces aussi démesurés et
l'utilisation de matériel de guerre
occasionnerait immanquablement des
blessés les autorités ont entravé les
secours au mépris de la vie humaine
concernant Serge day
excusez-moi un rajout rapide il y a un
vrai trou béant dans le rétex de la
gendarmerie retour d'expérience dans le
dénombrement des munitions utilisées il
y a un pot-pourri de près de 5000 bombes
type lacrymogène et jamais le détail
entre les deux types de bombe
lacrymogènes les faits et pourtant il y
a bien des bombes lacrymogènes qui en
effet pique les yeux c'est jamais
agréable mais il y a d'autres bombes
lacrymogène qu'on appelle les gem2l et
qui commettent des
plaies importantes et dommages sur les
gens qui les reçoivent je pense que si
une gm2l était balancée dans cette
assemblée évidemment on pourrait parler
de terrorisme quand vous le recevez que
vous êtes citoyen ben vous êtes
terrorisé et ça vient de l'État donc
évidemment que ça génère des choses
profondes chez chacun de nous je
voudrais surtout pas qu'on passe trop
vite sur
l'humanité des gens qui ont été touchés
et que derrière le tableau que vous
allez recevoir et consulter vous y
prendre
toutes ces images qui nous orbitent
encore aujourd'hui de moi
personnellement je voulais dire je me
suis pas rendu sur le théâtre des
opérations je suis resté en dehors de la
commune de Sainte-Soline et quant à
distance j'ai eu l'occasion de voir ce
qui se passait quand j'ai vu sur les
images de cnews le premier camarade
tombé au sol et ramener à l'extérieur
mis en sécurité pensait-on mais je suis
que ma place elle était plus large en
observateur lointain mais bien à la
chapelle-ardente sur le campement de
venzay et si vous aviez eu à la place de
mes yeux une caméra une poseriez pas les
mêmes questions vous seriez dans une
autre logique qui est de comment on fait
en sorte que ça n'arrive plus jamais
comment on fait en sorte que cette
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre soit
condamnée banni à jamais que les gm2l
qui sont des armes classées
semi-l'étales par les instances
internationales soient retirés de
l'Armada et qu'on revienne à des fins de
maintien de l'ordre qui fasse la part
belle la discussion voilà comme ça
existait longtemps moi j'ai eu affaire
un témoignage d'une personne qui a fait
toute sa carrière chez les gendarmes et
qui me disait qu'il n'avait jamais tapé
un seul manifestant c'était dans les
années 80 c'était à l'époque où il y
avait discussion entre les gens qui
manifestaient puis comme ils étaient à
peu près entendu ben ça dévier rarement
vous savez pas à dévier aujourd'hui la
seule réponse qu'on nous apporte quelque
soit nos arguments c'est la violence
policière et à ce titre là c'est bien
évidemment ce qui doit tous nous inviter
est-ce que dans les textes de loi qui
émaneront une proposition de textes de
loi qui mèneront votre commission est-ce
que la recherche sera de savoir ben
comment on fait en sorte que le droit de
manifester continue d'exister plutôt que
comment on fait en sorte de le juguler
et comment on puisque vous l'avez bien
compris la seule issue et je laisserai
la parole à Anne qui a des choses très
concrètes à vous donner là-dessus la
seule issue de sortie de ce dossier
c'est la démocratie et le respect du
droit
on va donner la parole à deux autres
membres de la commission d'enquête et
vous vous répondrez dans dans le droit
fil donc je vais d'abord donner la
parole à Monsieur Odoul donc je vous
laisserai répondre aux questions de
Monsieur Odoul et ensuite je passe la
parole à Monsieur Mathieu
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai l'impression à vous entendre que
soit vous habitez sur une autre planète
très très lointaine très très fumeuse
aussi
soit vous nous prenez pour des imbéciles
parce que dans votre dimension les
pierres aiguisées sont là pour allumer
des feux les h sont là pour couper du
bois les boules de pétanque sont là pour
organiser des tournois sympathiques et
pacifiques et même les policiers se sont
enfin les gendarmes se sont blessés
eux-mêmes si je vous entends monsieur
Fougerat ils se sont baissés eux-mêmes
voilà ou alors ce sont des blessures
psychologiques très clairement ce n'est
pas la réalité voilà c'est peut-être
votre réalité ce n'est pas la réalité si
on reprend votre votre rapport
sur la forme déjà qui n'est pas écrit en
français l'écriture inclusive à toutes
les lignes c'est n'importe quoi on a
même droit du ciel qui elle ne participe
c'est pas c'est pas du français
excusez-moi sur la forme c'est pas du
français sur le fond sur le fond
excusez-moi c'était un pamphlet contre
nos forces de l'ordre à pratiquement
toutes les pages vous avez des photos
qui incriminent jusqu'au galon qui sont
portés jusqu'au positionnement alors ça
vous avez bien étudié en revanche il y a
rien sur les éléments violents pourquoi
vous n'avez pas photographié les
éléments violents pourquoi ils ne sont
pas identifiés alors j'ai bien compris
qu'il y a un amalgame que finalement que
ce sont vos frères en habillement qu'on
est tous masqués on est tous casqués
pour se protéger de l'État terroriste et
des dangereuses forces de l'ordre qui
vont vous attaquer mais très clairement
c'est un pamphlet contre les forces de
l'ordre et vous minimisez ou vous
occulter totalement les responsabilités
des acteurs principaux qui sont les
éléments violents que ce soit des
éléments de votre collectif ou que ce
soit des éléments d'autres structures et
officines d'extrême gauche et puis
ensuite monsieur Legay vous avez dit
vous avez insisté beaucoup sur
l'humanité sur les violences contre les
êtres vivants moi j'ai une question très
simple qui va peut-être vous sembler
peut-être dérisoire mais pour nous qui a
du sens je pense
est-ce que pour vous les forces de
l'ordre policiers les gendarmes sont des
êtres vivants et est-ce qu'ils ont droit
aussi à l'humanité et au respect
allez-y monsieur greffe
après ces remarques de forme sur notre
rapport je vous réponds sur le fond
concernant
les manifestants en fait notre rôle en
tant qu'observateur des pratiques de
maniat Lord de maintien de l'ordre
pardon c'est d'observer la manière dont
le maintien de l'ordre est fait c'est de
nous assurer que l'État respecte les
libertés publiques et le droit de
réunion pacifique pour apprécier le
respect ou non de ces droits puisqu'en
effet le droit de réunion pacifique
n'est pas absolu et il y a des
ingérences qui peuvent être
effectivement en effet justifiés on
prend en compte
le contexte dans l'ensemble et y compris
le comportement des manifestants nous ce
qui nous ce qui nous intéresse l'objet
des observatoires en application du
droit international c'est de nous
assurer que l'État protège le droit de
manifester ni porte pas atteinte on
observe donc ici le maintien de l'ordre
et non les manifestants et cela dit on
s'intéresse et vous avez raison de le
souligner d'un point de vue légal à
l'usage de la force qui soit strictement
nécessaire et proportionné et donc ça
implique la prise en compte du contexte
et c'est ce qui apparaît dans notre
rapport puisqu'on n'a pas mis de
mentionner le comportement des
manifestants on n'a pas omis de
mentionner les jets de projectile les
jets donc de cocktail Molotov par contre
on peut pas mettre ici sur le même pied
la violence d'une part exercée par
l'État et ce qui peut être qualifié de
violence aussi par les manifestants nous
ce qu'on a observé ça ressort de notre
rapport et on vous l'a dit à 12h35 c'est
un usage de la force qui a l'initiative
des forces de l'ordre on a observé il y
avait sans doute des usages de la force
qui était justifiées mais globalement on
a observé que cet usage de la force il
était
disproportionnée et indiscriminer
notamment s'agissant des blessés
s'agissant des personnes qui étaient
très loin aux alentours donc oui nous
prenons en compte évidemment le
comportement des manifestants dans
l'appréciation de la stricte nécessité
de proportionnalité de l'usage de la
force ce qui implique aussi parfois une
mise en balance et ce qui est une chose
aussi complexe après il y a des cas sur
lesquels quand on tire sur des personnes
qui sont blessées quand on tire sur des
personnes qui sont strictement
pacifiques j'enfonce peut-être une porte
ouverte mais c'est non nécessaire et ce
n'est pas non plus proportionné que de
faire usage de la force
je passe la parole à Monsieur Mathieu
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
dame merci de vous être rendu à cette
convocation aujourd'hui
veuillez excuser les mois de certains
parlementaires qui nous n'étant pas
habitué à l'organisation des
manifestations à la réalité d'entre
elles et à la réalité des personnes qui
participent ont l'impression d'avoir le
diable devant eux moi-même ayant long
passé de syndicalistes je tremble de
peur en vous voyant j'espère vous
excuserez cette émotion
j'aimerais bien avoir si c'est possible
de manière officielle vous avez présenté
une liste que vous avez que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure docteur j'aimerais
bien qu'elle soit transmise de manière
officielle à la Commission en tant que
telle et qu'elle soit enregistrée comme
pièce avec alors je sais pas s'il y a la
caractérisation des blessures etc mais
ce sera intéressant j'espère que
le directeur général de la police
nationale a ce qui je l'avais demandé
une catégorisation des blessés à trouver
le temps cet été nous l'envoyer entre
deux contestations de la séparation des
pouvoirs
j'ai une autre question qui s'adresse
notamment l'observateur de la Ligue des
droits de l'homme
vous avez j'ai entendu tout à l'heure
5000 grenades tirées c'est ça c'est un
des comptes ministères de l'intérieur
c'est votre décompte c'est un décompte
presse donc j'aimerais des précisions
sur tout ça combien de temps ont duré
les affrontements exactement puisque
vous avez minute par minute avec une
pause d'environ une heure d'après ce que
j'ai compris quel est le temps
agrégé des des affrontements et des tirs
et enfin j'aimerais avoir une précision
parce que depuis tout à l'heure je me
pose une question quand j'entends le
déroulé des événements
avez-vous vu
avez-vous observé la Ligue des droits de
l'homme puisque vous couvriez un large
territoire avez-vous observer des
manœuvres de ravitaillement de la
gendarmerie vers le cordon qui était
dressé sur le bassin de ravitaillement
en grenade et matériel je vous remercie
oui donc je vous réponds sur l'usage
l'usage des armes j'avais combien aussi
d'apporter une précision puisque Gérald
Darmanin nous a expliqué qu'il ne
s'agissait pas de catégorie de matériel
de guerre au sens de du code de la
sécurité intérieure nombre de matériels
qui ont été utilisés relève de la
catégorie A2 qui est matériel de guerre
au sens des dispositions du code de la
sécurité intérieure
sur sur le décompte ce bilan il provient
directement du rapport au sujet des
observations d'ordre public de la
gendarmerie nationale qui nous dit la
gendarmerie nationale il y a eu 500015
grenades lacrymogènes 89 grenades de
désencerclement gel 40 dispositifs des
flagrants ASSR 81 tirent de LBD pour des
précisions sur ces armes vous aurez
aussi des précisions dans notre rapport
sur les dimensions techniques et les
impacts aussi que peuvent avoir ces
armes
en fait il a été fait usage nous on a
constaté entre 12h35 et
14h08 donc le moment de trêve soit 1h30
3 minutes et après il y a eu un nouvel
engagement de la force juste à la fin de
la trêve 15h08 mais très surétis entre
15h08 et 15h30 donc soit 22 minutes donc
en l'espace d'une heure 55 très
précisément nous on a constaté du coup
l'usage plusieurs milliers de fois
d'armes de guerre donc autrement dire au
moins deux en deux heures sont 5000
grenades qui ont été utilisées contre
les manifestants et à ce titre il serait
assez intéressant nous ce qu'on a pu
noter c'est que dans ces bilans
la gm2l c'est la seule grenade pour
laquelle les autorités n'ont pas voulu
donner de chiffres précis donc il
pourrait être pertinent aussi de
questionner les autorités pour savoir
effectivement combien de gm2l ont été
lancés durant cette période de temps et
sur donc c'est c'est 40 grenades
lacrymogènes c'est soit une minute une
pardon une toutes les 1,5 secondes je
rappelle que enfin ces 5000 grenades ça
représente quand même si on se rappelle
les événements de Rémi Fraisse c'est 20
fois plus que le soir de la mort de Rémi
Fraisse ça en dit long sur le caractère
manifestement
indiscriminé et disproportionné et
immodéré de l'usage de la violence et
sur votre seconde partie de questions
et oui oui effectivement on a constaté à
un moment c'était c'était un moment
qu'on a souligné aux alentours de 13h
mais vous l'aurez dans le dans le
déroulé de la manifestation de la noter
effectivement on voyait les légendes qui
couraient derrière les lignes de camions
avec des grosses caisses pour
ravitailler du coup à ce moment là en
grenade du coup l'ensemble des
moi je voulais savoir si vous aviez
constaté un ravitaillement externe c'est
à dire des véhicules externes au
dispositifs sur place qui seraient venu
ravitailler le dispositif sur place
je veux à ce moment-là c'était des
mouvements avec des gendarmes qui
étaient derrière les lignes de camion et
qui portaient les caisses de grenade
pour les ravitailler et peut-être
dernière petite précision sur le
décompte aussi des armes qui ont été
utilisées dans le reportage du coup
complément d'enquête à un moment c'est
filmé par le journaliste les gendarmes
ne savent même plus à combien de
grenades ils en sont en train de les
tirer ils ont perdu ils ont perdu les
comptes et ils disent on va faire les
comptes ce soir bon quoi qu'il en soit
de toute façon 5000 grenades en moins de
deux heures c'est quand même un nombre
très conséquent
et pour compléter sur le
c'est de ma faute
peut-être d'abord une précision Hassan
Soline
les forces de l'ordre n'ont pas nier
avoir eu des stratégies de ravitaille en
tout cas nous nous notons nous le
noterons
par ailleurs les cellules locaux que
nous avons pu consulter les forces de
l'ordre aussi par ailleurs parle de
ravitaillement cette fois-ci d'individus
violents
est-ce que vous avez fait des constats
de ce type là ou pas du tout donc
aborder la question du ravitaillement
qu'on le fasse de façon complète
et notamment pour être plus précis ce
qui a été évoqué cette fois-ci c'était
le fait que les il y a eu y compris
l'organisation de chaîne pour pour
alimenter cette fois-ci en projectile
sur vraiment je vous invite à revoir
l'intervention de Thierry Vincent vous
avez auditionné ici je pense qu'il
décrit parfaitement bien ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui voilà c'est
je pense très fidèle il a une très bonne
compréhension et que au départ ces
manifestations il y a pas de gens qui il
y a des gens qui ne savent pas comment
ils vont agir on ne sait pas non plus
face à l'émotion et face à la violence
en réciprocité comment réagit tout à
l'heure je faisais état de d'une
blessure d'un proche vous savez ce que
ça peut générer chez les uns les autres
quand on voit son enfant sa mère etc
toucher dans ses chair par des forces
par des armes moi ce que je ce que
j'espère et j'espère que votre
commission permettra de ce chemin ce
chemin là et je crois savoir que le
dernier auditionner c'est le Ministre
Voldemort pardon qu'on n'a pas le dire
son nom
il travaille auditionné et j'espère
qu'il y aura autant de questions à
charge
pour qu'il puisse expliquer les choix
qui ont été faits dans du maintien du
désordre public à Sainte Soline j'espère
qu'il y aura si ça n'est pas à travers
votre commission d'enquête une
commission d'enquête dédiée pour
détailler la chaîne de commandement et
comment on en est arrivé à ces décisions
de faire acheminer des milliers de
bombes 3000 hommes en armes tous ces
hélicoptères de les acculer contre un
fortin ou finalement ils se retrouvent
dans une situation où il y avait aucune
aucun échappatoire on a créé les
arbitrages qui ont été faits et les
décisions stratégiques qui ont été pris
dans la chaîne de commandement ont
généré cette situation d'extrême
violence il est absolument impératif que
ce type d'opération de maintien de
l'ordre qui feront et qui fait la honte
de la France au niveau des instances
internationales ne se reproduisent pas
et je vous signale à ce niveau là que
nous allons mettre tout en œuvre pour
que la vérité sur Sainte Soline et les
chaînes de commandement et les
signalement y compris au niveau des
instances nationales et des cours de
droits de l'homme etc puisse être fait
je vous rappelle que lié à un dossier de
Sainte-Soline il y a eu un rapport de
six rapporteurs de Nations Unies et qui
viennent interpeller son imminence en
personne monsieur Macron
quand au fait d'avoir noté que des
engagements internationaux profonds
n'étaient pas respecté dans le cadre
spécifique de sainte Soline ça doit nous
questionner et je compte sur vous
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président pour pleinement étendre le
domaine de compétences de votre
commission pour qu'elles permettent
qu'en effet ça ne se reproduise plus
jamais
monsieur Legay ça n'est pas nous qui
définissons le périmètre ça a été une
décision qui a été prise par la
représentation nationale donc le
périmètre il est connu donc
nous serions dans la désobéissance si
nous irions dans une optique ou
justement nous ne respecterions pas le
cadre qui nous a été défini donc voilà
en tout cas ça n'est pas qualifié les
3000 hommes en face de groupuscules
violents il rentrera dans le champ de
l'enquête
en toute en toute état de cause
nous nous tenons à faire en sorte que
l'on aille comme je l'ai dit en début en
début d'audition vers l'objectivation
plus possible de de ce qui a pu se
dérouler là je passe la parole à
Monsieur taverne et puis ensuite je vous
laisserai répondre et puis monsieur
Mendes souhaitait également intervenir
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs alors moi
j'ai plusieurs à plusieurs questions
vous parlez systématiquement d'un de
guerre détenu par les policiers vous
parlez de violences policières on
commence à y être habitué
quand nous avons auditionné les les
syndicats puisque cette commission
d'enquête parle également des
manifestations dans les cortèges
parisiens
quasiment tout ça sauf la CGT mais bon
il faut pas étonné
ont bien dit que les défilés c'était
déroulés correctement
grâce aux forces de l'ordre
qui ont assuré la sécurité des
manifestants puisque c'est leur première
mission à force de l'ordre assurer la
sécurité des manifestants
et ce sont les organisations syndicales
qui le disent
et elles nous disent également qu'il
avait des des groupescules violents
qui étaient parfaitement
identifié donc par rapport aux
organisations syndicales comment vous
pouvez aujourd'hui dire qu'il y a un
problème avec le maintien de l'ordre à
la française comment vous pouvez dire
qu'aujourd'hui il a des violences
policières que les organisations
organisations syndicales disent bien que
les forces de l'ordre ont accompli
correctement leur mission pour pouvoir
manifester
comme dans un État de droit
c'est ce que vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure est un droit et déjà partie au
moment où on participe à une
manifestation interdite l'État de droit
sur l'applique à soi-même ensuite vous
parlez de dame de guerre on va rentrer
vraiment dans le détail puisque mon
collègue lui l'a dit les haches c'est
pour couper du bois etc les masques à
gaz
que certains manifestants ont porté
c'est bien de la catégorie A2 non
c'est bien un matériel de guerre donc
pourquoi vous justifiez alors que les
manifestants viennent avec des armes de
guerre oui c'est vous pouvez vérifier
vous inquiétez pas c'est un sujet que je
maîtrise plutôt bien donc pourquoi dans
ce cas là vous parlez de de masque à gaz
alors que vous utilisez vous-même vous
étiez vous-même des matériels de guerre
et ensuite que dans ce cas là que
proposer vous
attendez
que proposez-vous à partir du moment où
des gendarmes des policiers
ont à faire à des individus qui leur
balance des cocktails Molotov et
cocktails je rappelle catégorie A
monsieur tu as même respecter le temps
de parole
contre les Panzer allemand et on utilise
en fait des cocktails Motors contre des
êtres humains vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et dernière question puisque vous
pas de maintien dans la française dans
ce cas là j'attends vos propositions
puisque je ne pense pas que
vous êtes allé voir ce qui se passe dans
votre pays
dans des grandes démocraties par exemple
en 2021 au Pays-Bas les policiers ont
tiré sur des émeutiers par exemple par
exemple et c'est l'honneur de la France
puisque vous l'avez vous lavez répété
tout à l'heure juste titre c'est que
s'il n'y a pas eu de mort c'est grâce au
professionnelalisme des policiers
aux professionnels des policiers donc il
faut aussi remettre un petit peu
l'église au centre du village donc
j'attends vos propositions vous les
retirez les grenades donc que vont faire
les policiers par rapport par rapport
justement aux armes qui sont utilisés
contre elles merci Monsieur taverne je
laisse donc la délégation répondre
absolument et merci du coup de me donner
l'occasion de répondre à la question de
Madame Maximy à laquelle je n'ai pas eu
le temps de répondre tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire justement
pour sortir de cette crise ben en fait
la solution la plus simple c'est quand
même de créer des espaces de débat de
dialogue de discussion et des espaces
qui des espaces s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît laissez-moi je pense que là
c'est mon temps de m'exprimer
tout à l'heure
et
bien en fait alors laissez répondre
madame pestier s'il vous plaît
et pour ça déjà par exemple il faudrait
se mettre d'accord quand monsieur Odoul
c'est dommage qu'il soit parti quand
monsieur odoun nous dit qu'on n'habite
pas sur la même planète et bien
peut-être qu'effectivement on habite pas
sur la même planète j'aurais bien aimé
lui demander son avis quand aux
conclusions du rapport du GIEC quant au
fait que la semaine dernière on est une
étude scientifique qui soit sortie dans
Science qui nous dit que on vient de
déplacer de déplacer la limite
planétaire de l'eau bleue c'est à dire
de l'eau douce facilement accessible
pour l'espèce humaine que dans les
années les décennies à venir on va avoir
des précipitations complètement
aléatoires avec des tempêtes comme
maintenant on a carrément des ouragans
qui se forment dans la Méditerranée
grâce au réchauffement climatique ça
c'est quand même l'innovation et quand
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure ces
périodes de sécheresse de plusieurs
années qui vont que qui vont nous
arriver dans le futur et on a déjà vu
cette année on a eu énormément de chance
cet été qu'il n'y ait pas de pénurie
d'eau et on a eu de la chance uniquement
de la chance il faudrait pas croire que
c'est parce que Monsieur Macron a dit à
la télé qu'il fallait couper son robinet
en ce brossant les dents que on a évité
les coupures d'eau on les a évité
uniquement parce qu'on a eu un mois
d'avril très pluvieux qui a rechargé les
nappes au dernier moment et parce qu'on
a eu un mois un été très pluvieux qui a
permis de limiter l'irrigation à tel
point même qu'il reste actuellement de
l'eau dans la bassine de nausée et donc
pour répondre effectivement en fait j'en
arrive à la question c'est à dire que on
va avoir des conflits d'usage liés à
l'eau et alors ici on ne parle que de
notre sujet mais évidemment d'autres
conflit d'usage dans le futur et ces
conflit d'usage ne sont pas prêtes
s'arrêter et donc comment on les règles
est-ce qu'on les règle uniquement par un
dialogue de sourd et on vous envoie des
grenades jm2l ou est-ce qu'on les règle
en se mettant tout le monde autour d'une
table et en discutant encore une fois
rationnellement
le au lendemain de la première
manifestation de sainte Soline en
octobre et je m'en souviens parce que
moi c'est là où vraiment je me suis
impliquée dans ce mouvement
on a eu le ministre de la transition
énergétique qui a brandi une étude
l'étude du bergerm qui allait qui disait
selon lui que les bassines allaient
namener que du positif pour les rivières
et qu'on avait là une étude d'impact
qu'il fallait que les écolos on arrête
de s'inquiéter et en fait à quel moment
on a un espace de discussion autour de
cette étude par exemple lorsque moi je
produis la contre expertise de ce
rapport et que j'y montre que le modèle
n'est pas assez fiable à une échelle
très locale n'est pas assez fiable à une
échelle temporelle pour évaluer l'impact
de ses bassines ou pour en mesurer
l'éventuelle bénéfice
on a aucun endroit où tenir ce débat
nous avons bien évidemment proposé au
BRGM de d'avoir un débat public on a eu
absolument aucune réponse et là à un
moment je me suis dit un moment on a
publiquement ce genre d'espace d'échange
en fait est-ce qu'on a un espace
d'échange public pour se batailler à
coup d'arguments vraiment où on serait
entendu et bien non on en a pas il faut
bien le il faut bien le dire en fait on
a même de demander aux associations
environnementales est-ce que ça vous
sert à quelque chose que je vous
produise un vrai contre rapport et ils
m'ont dit mais évidemment que non le
juge n'aura même pas le temps ni même
les compétences de lire deux rapports
scientifiques et de se faire un avis
dessus donc en fait voilà vraiment je
pose ces questions dans quel espace de
discussion démocratique on pourrait
régler cette crise et cette crise
franchement encore une fois c'est elle
marque beaucoup parce que cette lutte à
cristallisé mais en fait c'est que le
début des conflits d'usage de des
ressources communes qui arrivent avec
l'ensemble de la crise environnementale
et je pourrais continuer on a dans la
Vienne le département où j'habite on a
la base rationnelle donc de ces projets
de
bassines qui sont censés être les études
à chamuser on va nous carrément on a
dans notre commission locale de l'eau
donc la science qui est censé à peu près
piloter ou pas c'est sébacine
je me permets cette fois-ci de recentrer
le débat encore une fois je comprends la
transparence des institutions qui
contrôlent
en tant que président de recentrer les
débats évidemment vous êtes un collectif
qui défend une cause nous avons précisé
que l'objectif de notre commission
d'enquête concernait cette fois-ci
l'organisation des manifestations et à
ce titre nous n'allions pas ouvrir le
débat environnemental aussi légitime
puisse-t-il être dans la mesure où ça
n'est pas le périmètre de notre
commission d'enquête donc permettez-moi
de clore le débat sur ce point je vais
passer la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur et puis ensuite monsieur
Mendes qui souhaitait également
s'exprimer
une question que il y aura une question
quand même
qu'il y est un sujet démocratique en
France
comme dans plusieurs démocraties à
travers le monde et notamment l'Union
européenne je pense qu'ici personne n'en
doute et parfois
affront renversé c'est à dire pas en
apportant les mêmes propositions en vue
de solution on n'est pas tous d'accord
là on n'est pas de la même formation
politique
dans le rapport est-ce que j'en ferai
pas je pense que oui ce sera pas son
central mais je poserai la question du
rapport à la démocratie du rapport à la
décision parce que ça fait partie du
sujet bon d'accord du sujet sur comment
on régule la conflictualité comment on
régule la confrontation démocratique
dans une démocratie qui parfois plus de
mal qu'auparavant pour la régler y
compris que ça vous a pas échappé
ce sujet ne sera pas central mais je
l'évacurai pas
je suis pas sûr que mes remarques soient
partagées par tous en tout cas mais
constats le seront parce que je viens de
le faire les options les propositions
peut-être pas on verra en fraise je ne
sais pas ce n'est pas central encore une
fois un rapport à venir il y a une autre
question à laquelle on ne répondez pas
Madame pastier
et celle-ci elle est très importante
quelle que soit les causes considérées
quel que soit d'ailleurs la temporalité
considérée de la même de celle de la
commission d'enquête depuis un très
grand nombre d'années désormais depuis
des années fin 90 début 2000 quel que
soit la cause
la loi travail la réforme des retraites
pourrions débattre de la réforme des
retraites comme nous pouvons débattre de
la côte environnementale que vous portez
ne feront pas bien sûr il y a la
survenance d'un certain nombre
d'individus violents
organisé en vue de commettre des
violences nous avons systématiquement en
tout cas moi je me suis attaché monsieur
le Président bien sûr aussi veiller à
distinguer celles et ceux qui
manifestent celles et ceux qui viennent
pourront découdre il y a des individus
qui viennent pour en découvrir les
services de renseignement le note
bon certes ce sont des services de
l'État sont peut-être orientés enfin ils
font leur job de façon générale il y a
des organisations syndicales qui le
notent elles l'ont dit ici très
explicitement à votre à votre place au
menu des organisations syndicales qui
est indiquaient que il recommandait à
leur propre adhérents de ne pas aller
manifester sur des manifestations
interdites c'est leur choix je dis pas
que c'est la vérité absolue en tout cas
nous l'avons constaté est-ce que oui ou
non vous faites le constat Hassan comme
ailleurs
qu'il y a des individus organisés pour
être violents
et qui viennent s'infiltrer dans des
causes non pas pour les défendre non pas
pour les porter non pas pour participer
de façon chorale au revendications qui
sont les vôtres et que j'estime être
légitime je les partage pas toutes mais
je les trouve légitimes et démocratiques
est-ce que vous considérez que oui ou
non il y a des individus violents qui
viennent pour en découdre nous on
s'intéresse à ça et aux effets néfastes
pour l'organisation démocratique
elle-même parfois pour celles et ceux
qui portent des coches par son je parle
aux organisations syndicales notamment
avec pas que parce que le trouble c'est
la déformation du message et social par
exemple qui est porté ou
environnementale qui est porté est-ce
que oui ou non c'est un problème est-ce
que oui ou non vous le notez est-ce que
oui ou non vous considérez qu'il est
aussi comme de la nôtre de votre
responsabilité dans tenir compte
sur le premier aspect et je vous
remercie d'avoir une attention
particulière à ça c'est bien un problème
de démocratie tout à l'heure elle
Marouane a commencé à le développer mais
très clairement je suis très inquiet
quand à la suite des événements parce
que ce qui aujourd'hui
crée du
dysfonctionnement c'est le fait que la
justice administrative soit dit après
travaux ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui génère c'est le cas c'est le cas
les arrêtés sont pas suspensives et
est-ce que oui ou non vous constatez
qu'il y a des individus violents est-ce
que c'est un problème est-ce que comment
le régule
donc moins de périphrase
excusez-moi aujourd'hui c'est pas ce
chemin là puisque par exemple dans le
plan le programme de la nouvelle loi
d'orientation agricole il s'agirait que
les bassines soient classés d'intérêt
général majeur et qu'à ce titre ça les
procédures administratives soient
largement allégées chez nous évidemment
que ça ne va pas atténuer les tensions
c'est l'inverse qu'on demande voilà donc
je reviens là-dessus sur le fait que des
manifestations
créent des tensions et sur le fait qu'il
y a des sujets en fait qui créent des
tensions mais quand il s'agit d'un
domaine vital comme l'eau ou en fait
quand la dernière goutte d'eau elle est
passée elle est bu il y a plus que la
mort derrière et que cet enjeu il soit
tellement important et qu'elle encourage
certains d'entre nous à se dépasser à
aller au-delà du cadre militant que
jusqu'à maintenant c'était imposé c'est
tout à fait dans l'ordre des choses
c'est en relation avec ce qu'on juge
aujourd'hui de parfaitement
insatisfaisant face à l'urgence
climatique qui s'impose à nous et donc
ben non on va pas vous aider dans la
typologie des violences on va pas vous
aider dans la typologie de qu'est-ce qui
fait que des gens c'est certainement la
colère et c'est certainement
l'incompréhension peuvent sortir de leur
gond et adopter des comportements qui
n'étaient pas les leurs jusqu'à lors il
faut qu'on interroge les racines du mal
c'est évident et ça se soignera à grands
coups de démocratie je ne vois pas
d'alternative comme aurait dit une
certaine Margaret
en tout cas c'est
et pardon si un élément important parce
que nous notre niveau
ah oui bien sûr ah oui excusez-moi
pardon
on n'oublie pas
que le bilan il est bilatéral chez nous
il y a eu plus de 200 blessés et encore
on les oreilles etc on verra et puis les
dommages de l'âme ils sont pas mesurés
sont difficiles à mesurer
j'espère que Monsieur taverne vous ne
considérez pas non plus que les 40
blessés au niveau de la gendarmerie soit
quelque chose de satisfaisant en terme
de bilan et de maintien de l'ordre et
d'objectifs qui visaient soit disant à
limiter un maximum les baissés 250
blessés ça n'est pas un bon résultat ça
n'est pas une bonne opération de
maintien de l'ordre et donc je tiens à
dire ici qu'on est tout aussi inquiet
pour nos camarades mais sauf qu'entre
nous on essaye de soigner on essaie
d'être solidaire et notamment
d'accompagner sur les soins et je crains
que les 3000 agents qui ont eu à jeter
des bombes sur un public qui aurait pu
être leur petite sœur leur petit frère
faire leur papy leur mamie et ben il y a
pas eu d'accompagnement psychologique
derrière je pense qu'il serait
nécessaire parce que quand on fait
montre d'une telle violence évidemment
qu'on n'est pas de bois et je tiens à
vous faire remonter ici un témoignage
moi qui m'inquiète très fort de d'un
jeune c'était essentiellement des jeunes
garmobil qu'on avait en face de nous de
moins de 25 ans et d'un de ces jeunes
qui s'est retrouvé justement en
situation de blocage des soins de
blocage des véhicules de secours et qui
entend monsieur Darmanin Voldemort
pardon
nier c'est évident cela lui il habite
dans un petit village au fin fond des
montagnes il a parlé dans son village
comment il vit avec cette honte là
comment il vit avec la réalité d'un
ministre qui ment l'évidence et comment
il vit avec ce fait de savoir que il a
servi à ça comment on accompagne et donc
j'espère que après ça de Sologne quelque
chose qui va ressembler au Rwanda une
espèce de commission de dialogue et de
reconstitution aujourd'hui je ne salue
plus les forces de l'ordre les grader
avec qui on travaille depuis 7 ans en
réalité parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
quelque chose qui est vraiment
profondément
atteint dans l'enjeu républicain j'en
appelle à la reconstruction j'en appelle
à ce qu'on dépasse cet événement et que
surtout je le répète vous comme nous on
est un objectif commun c'est que ça ne
se reproduise plus jamais
monsieur Mendes je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président je voulais
revenir sur deux trois points et deux
trois remarques juste pour la précision
ce sera la dernière question puisque
nous avions dit deux heures d'échange il
est 18h12 donc voilà la dernière
intervention et puis ensuite on laissera
évidemment la délégation réponse et puis
je lèverai l'audition merci monsieur le
Président pour cette cette information
complémentaire alors deux choses soient
les grenades dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure depuis tout à l'heure et de la
mort de Rémi fresque que voulait
absolument mettre en parallèle de ce qui
s'est passé à saint-celine on rappelle
que après la mort malheureusement les
grenades qui étaient responsables ont
été interdites par le ministre de
l'Intérieur de l'époque Bernard
Cazeneuve donc les grenades qui ont été
utilisés à Sainte-Souline ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes que celles qui avaient
été utilisées à lors de la mort de de
Rémi fresh premier point deuxième point
sur la démocratie donc vous parlez de
tout à l'heure je me permets cette
remarque aussi un vote qu'il passe au
Parlement que vous soyez d'accord ou pas
d'accord avec un vote au Parlement c'est
la démocratie que c'est exprimée on
prend l'exemple d'ailleurs avec mon
collègue Mounir bel-amitié de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et la cons
de pouvoir manifester ce week-end là et
que vous avez vous avez quand même tenu
à manifester et à mettre potentiellement
en danger des manifestants et étant
donné que quand on est responsable d'une
manifestation en tant que président
d'association ou responsable
d'association on a la responsabilité
pénale aussi derrière une question pour
pour mettre
qui est présent en tant qu'avocat vous
pouvez nous expliquer la différence
justement entre une police qui
intervient quand une manifestation est
autorisée et une police qui intervient
quand une manifestation est interdite
parce que elle n'a pas le même rôle pour
vous nous le rappeler parce que vous en
parlez pas dans vos différents rapports
et c'est important de rappeler que le
rôle des forces de l'ordre n'est pas le
même à ce moment-là deuxième point c'est
comment avez-vous fait pour réunir
autant de personnes qui viennent des
quatre coins de la France et de l'Europe
ça ça nous interpelle parce que c'est
même la base de cette commission
d'enquête comprendre comment vous avez
pu le faire tout en sachant que dans
d'autres pays certaines manifestations
avaient dégénéré vous m'avez coupé la
parole monsieur le Président au tout
début pendant au moins 20 secondes
justement on était revenu à zéro non
alors
je me suis assuré et après vous avoir
coupé la parole nous ayons revenu
comment faites-vous parce que vous savez
que certaines manifestations dont en
Allemagne en Italie avaient été avaient
débordé et donc il y avait un risque
potentiel que se débordement arrive sur
Sainte Céline et la dernière question
que j'avais à vous poser s'il n'y avait
pas eu les forces de l'ordre
qu'auriez-vous fait exactement lors de
cette manifestation
moi j'aimerais j'aimerais vous répondre
sur une petite partie de votre question
la première
concernant l'interdiction des grenades
d'if-4 je crois si je dis pas de bêtises
suite à au décès de Rémi Fraisse il me
semble je suis pas un spécialiste non
plus peut-être vous avez des
informations différentes de bien mais il
me semble que ça a été remplacé par les
gm2l
il y avait un argumentaire de moindre
quantité d'explosifs
mais qui est un explosif manifestement
différent et là je rentre dans un champ
que je ne maîtrise pas donc qui est un
explosif différent et dont on m'a dit
qu'il aurait une vitesse d'explosion
plus rapide et donc susceptible de
générer des ondes de choc que j'évoquais
dans une précédente intervention plus
puissante et plus destructrice donc en
fait je sais pas s'il a le remplacement
de la grief 4 par la gm2l est réellement
un progrès en terme de maintien de
l'ordre et en termes de sécurité des
manifestants qui reçoivent ces objets là
merci
je ne faisais que rétablir des faits
c'est tout je ne demandais pas ce qu'on
a un débat sur les grenades c'était pour
répondre
et ce débat néanmoins il est il est très
intéressant parce qu'il fait la
dangerosité il fallait blesser il fait
le fait que cette opération de maintien
de l'ordre elle doit pas faire école
surtout pas
juste une petite chose si vous le
souhaitez j'ai des photos dans mon
téléphone que j'ai pris moi-même des
dégâts que provoque ces grenades je
parlais tout à l'heure des de chair
arracher ça ça ne se situe pas
ça on fait là dessus ce qu'on appelle
une cicatrisation dirigée c'est-à-dire
que ça prend des semaines de pansement
pour que la peau repousse c'est ça la
réalité de ces c'est c'est des
conséquences de ces objets là et ce
serait intéressant moi j'ai pas
d'éléments non plus sur ce point-là mais
ce sera intéressant d'observer à quels
endroits les personnes ont été blessées
par ces choses-là est-ce que c'est dans
le rayon de 100 mètres qui en effet une
zone qui paraît particulièrement
dangereuse ou bien ce que c'est plus
loin je te laisse la parole
moi je trouve que vous avez une question
très très pertinente très intéressante à
la fin bah oui bah alors celle qui on
verra à la deuxième que j'ai pas noté
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait fait s'il y avait
pas eu de force de l'ordre c'est une
vraie bonne question ben on serait allé
voir la bassine et les gens qui sont
venus de l'autre bout de la France ils
auraient pu voir pourquoi on appelle ça
une méga bassine et puis je sais pas si
vous avez l'occasion d'y aller mais je
réédite mon invitation devenir faire un
tour dans le marais poitevin devenir
dans un trou en fait quand on rentre
dans une méga bassine on a compris ça
allait à l'encontre du sens de
l'histoire ça allait en compte du bon
sens que ça allait à l'encontre du bon
cycle de l'eau c'était juste une
solution techno que les permettre de
continuer le maïs parce que c'est ça
dont il est question coûte que coûte et
quel que soit comment c'est vécu par les
habitants quelle que soit les
conséquences sur le milieu naturel quel
que soit le conséquence sur les autres
agriculteurs qui ont à subir les
remplissages de ces bassines là et c'est
très très pédagogique et donc pourquoi
est-ce que notre lutte elle résonne à
travers la France aujourd'hui à travers
l'Europe mais je pense que vous le savez
on est face aujourd'hui à une situation
en termes écologique et en termes d'eau
qui est
catastrophique j'habite la deuxième zone
humide de France qui s'appelle le marais
poitevin la biodiversité est en train de
s'y éteindre à vitesse grand V donc nos
motivations elles sont là elles
devraient être les mêmes que les vôtres
à savoir faire un monde plus juste un
monde simplement vivable et donc dans
cette optique là les questions d'eau
sont des questions qui nous invitent
énormément c'est l'élément numéro un sur
lequel il faut que nous fassions société
l'eau ne peut être un bien de marché
comme les autres on ne peut pas spéculer
sur l'eau de toutes les formes de vie en
ont besoin et donc faut comprendre
pourquoi il est impératif que votre
mouvement la République en marche
entendent dès à présent notre demande de
moratoire le fait de stopper tous ces
projets de stockage de méga bassine à
l'aune de afin que toute la vérité
scientifique puisse être dite afin que
les conformités avec les engagements
internationaux et avec les textes de loi
européen sur la directive cadre sur
l'eau soit vérifiée et à ce titre là
quand tout ça sera sur les rangs vous
verrez on aura d'autres modalités de
partage et on sera tous en mesure de
mettre toute l'énergie qu'on met
aujourd'hui pour lutter contre pour
lutter pour de manière à construire des
solutions partagées dans le sens de
l'intérêt général c'est là qu'on doit
faire politique c'est là qu'on doit
faire société merci monsieur le député
très bien c'était le mot de la fin en
tout cas je tiens à remercier non mais
non mais monsieur Mendes nous nous avons
voilà nous avons une réponse de la part
de la délégation je tiens une nouvelle
fois à remercier la présence des
représentants du collectif bassin non
merci ainsi que ma représentant de la
Ligue des droits de l'homme et nous je
vais
lever notre audition tout en vous
rappelant chers collègues que notre
prochaine réunion de commission
d'enquête est prévue donc jeudi le 5
octobre à 9h30 la salle est fort
probablement celle-ci mais cela vous
sera précisé ultérieurement pour un
échange avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
je vous remercie et je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée